congratulations you've made it
congratulations you've made the strategy
congratulations congratulations
[Music]
welcome to this episode of trash taste
hope you guys are doing well and enjoy
yourself have a nice season get
comfortable get out get out get a little
popcorn or something i don't know
because uh because we're going to the
movies
what are we saying what is this pov
you're on a date with connor yeah get
yourself comfortable uh i'll go in the
movies
on a date with the boys right i don't
know what else to say all right all
right you got me okay
how you guys doing it's good it's uh
november where the [ __ ] has this year
gone god dude and i can i can say this
because this is we don't have a buffer
anymore um so whatever we talk about
no i mean we're filming this on tuesday
and it's going to go out saturday which
is i think the first time in trash taste
history that'll have one of the trash
days that starts with the
there's no um hot topics to talk about i
don't think there is any way at least uh
i watched the dune movie is that a hot
topic
i mean people are talking about it
it's it's a movie yeah it's something i
saw right now how was it [ __ ] amazing
really i don't i don't like i genuinely
don't understand like normally right
online okay okay people love to be
critics right about movies right no you
go into rotten tomatoes you go onto imdb
yeah all sorts of self-acclaimed critics
right yeah
and you know most of the time
i'm okay
with opposite opinions because i've you
know i always want to know like what the
opposite opinion is right it's like okay
if i really enjoyed something right then
i want to see like how bad it is like if
i really hated something i want to know
you know why people might have enjoyed
it right i'm usually open to it i think
this might be the first time in my life
where i don't understand the opposite
opinion because i saw so many people on
like twitter and like rotten tomatoes
like raiding dune is like oh it was [ __ ]
it was a disappointment and i'm like did
you watch the same movie that i watched
because it was genuinely the first time
where i'm like i actually don't
understand your criticism
like because is that why are you brain
dead yeah why it's like were you asleep
during the movie like so what about it's
so good then because i i'm gonna watch
it oh yeah but i'm watching like every
other movie except that movie so like
for one it's like one of the uh so i'm
like a massive fan of the books yeah
okay i haven't read the book okay but
that's alright i still enjoy it yes
absolutely so i went with a couple of my
friends uh one of them has read the
books and the other two hadn't read the
book right so it was good to find out if
you needed to be a fan of the books or
not luckily everyone enjoyed it yeah but
i think it's because the movie did a
really good job of like picking and
choosing
like the right information to leave in
the movie okay because there's a lot of
information in from the books that they
didn't include in the movie naturally i
mean that's just how that's just how
book adaptations i mean dune is like
especially dune is like so [ __ ]
extensive when it comes to its law like
literally the first book at the back of
the book there's a literal glossary of
terms that you need to understand to
read the book
like that's how it's just like its own
terms it's made up which is terms that
it's made like frank herbert who was the
creator was like so like he was so five
head with this [ __ ] because like you
know you also have to understand this
was written in like 1965 like it's a 50
year old sci-fi book is that old it's
really old yeah i i've heard it's like
visually and and the
sound is amazing oh yeah like
i'm gonna
this might be a hot take but i think it
is one of hans zimmer's best soundtracks
that is that is some fighting words
because he's he's had some amazing
sounds like i thought
like lion king soundtrack epic inception
he did like lion king he did lanky what
did you didn't know he did lion king no
yeah
and john
he's solo carries yeah
no he did the lion king sound no [ __ ]
yeah are you serious yep
yeah but he did you know he did lion
king he did inception he obviously
basically every christopher nolan movie
he did yeah and uh and i thought he
peaked at like interstellar right like
that's like the one soundtrack everyone
says it's like yeah [ __ ] amazing
movies so what did you what would you
give the movie out of ten if i dare ask
oh
your score because archaic system
judging movies yeah
sure uh i'd give it like a strong nine
oh wow yeah well i'm just gonna watch it
yeah i was gonna watch it because the
biggest criticism i've heard if you can
even call it a criticism really is that
so much of it depends on
part two because i've heard it's just
it's not a full movie it's just it
covers the first half of the first book
yeah and it's a two and a half hour
movie
when they really stood too they'll
probably do the whole you can watch the
first movie before the second one yeah
like a bundle package
yeah yeah yeah you can watch uh uh
infinity war before end game yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah what i've heard about part one of
dune is that it's not like say you know
avengers infinity war or like a lot of
people trying to build a whole world
yeah yeah where where you don't get like
a natural story arc it's just you get
half a star yeah i thought it's abrupt
yeah yeah yeah yeah it does kind of just
end with that piss people off yeah and i
think as well the other big thing is
that i feel a lot of the criticism i saw
is that i think they kind of almost
gave it a little bit of false
advertising with like the trailer
because i watched the trailer of it and
there's like you know it looks like an
action sci-fi yeah the thing is dune is
not an action sci-fi it's a political
cipher yeah it's one of the things where
it's tough though you can't you can't
market politics yeah yeah which is like
just like your fans are crying
i'm
you can market politics but in a movie
it's kind of hard to be like and then he
signed the paper
yeah yeah
i mean that's just like that's just like
a lot of mecca and mate in a nutshell
people are just like oh giant robot's
got a pvp and then they're like wait a
minute i'm already invested in these
colonies and the politics of these
colonies what is all this government
[ __ ] what is what's going on you
don't tell someone game of thrones is
like a political thriller of
backstabbing and stuff like it's got
dragons and zombies yeah yeah exactly
and then like
yeah because i watched the trailer and
literally the entire trailer is
it's like 80 of it is a lot of like
fighting scenes yeah but what's funny is
that like
all of like all the fighting scenes in
the trailer are all the fighting scenes
in the movie oh okay okay all right okay
okay and so i'm not gonna watch the
trailer now because of spoilers
no so i can see why like i think people
might have been maybe like misinformed
about it if they never like read the
books or anything yeah maybe i don't
know since living in japan i've i've
been doing this thing where i just don't
look at reviews before and after the
movie yeah full stop i just do not look
at reviews anymore i just look at the
movie i watch a trailer i'm like it
looks okay yeah or if sometimes i don't
even watch the trailer i just pick one
yeah i just go to the cinema and i watch
it right around i've been really
enjoying movies a lot i think i think
that's the right thing yeah that's the
right thing it's hard because sometimes
i watch a movie and i'm like
i think that was good
but i need someone else to also tell me
those guys
because that's the age we live in yeah
because i experienced that recently with
uh i'm sure i don't think we can spoil
it but we were asked to watch something
by a company yeah right
uh and it was the first time did you
have to make that so obvious
okay but it was the first time that uh i
had watched something i got like given
early access to something so even if i
wanted to there is no way i could check
whether this what i was watching was
good
or not i can't wait to talk about that
yeah yeah we're gonna be we're gonna be
talking about that on another another
episode but it was like such a weird
experience for me to be like
huh i i think this is good
i like that my opinion i think is right
but uh doesn't it doesn't it it could be
wrong it doesn't suck that at the end of
the day it just boils down to i liked it
what is it only me yeah i think that
i've started to like from doing this a
lot i've just because now i don't treat
movies as like i want to watch that one
film that's good it's like i want to
just do something for three hours that
like lets me shut off yeah so i just go
to movies watching anything literally
anything yeah um my problem with movies
right now is that i have such a short
attention span like
because i need i want to shut off in the
movie but i need to know that it's worth
my time right right that's that's like
it's it's like taking a leap of faith
and the thing is if you take that leap
of faith and that movie ends up being
good then you enjoy it way way more but
i just i just have like i don't have the
attention span to sit through enough
shitty movies that i'm just like
okay i'm just not in the mood for this
yeah i'm not sure what's changed i don't
know why i'm like because i'll tell you
what i've been doing actually to to
offset this which i know you think i'm a
psychopath okay which is whenever i get
recommended random clips on youtube for
a movie i haven't watched i see that
clip and sometimes it's like a banger
clip and i'm just like all right this
movie is worth watching i'm gonna watch
in time so you have to basically watch
like a portion of the movie before
you're like
the whole thing there needs to be
something to sell me on this movie it
doesn't even need to be like a high
scoring movie or something that people
like everyone recommends there just
needs to be
something about this movie that i'm just
like okay this is it is that this is
there no part of you that just wants to
turn up to a movie and know nothing
about it and just watch something oh
yeah i mean that i think that's the
issue of watching things for a job yeah
you know what i mean well i watch enough
things for a job blind anyway that
we're in my free time in my downstairs i
want to know that this [ __ ]
because if it's not then it's just
another job
i understand that
it's weird because even if the movie
isn't as good as i would like it to be i
still get the same level of enjoyment
from just being in the environment
getting to experience watching something
even if it's [ __ ] i'm like i think you
just like the cinema experience i really
do and also i just like having i
sometimes it's not but it's nice
watching something yeah that's bad so i
can i can have a frame of reference
right i can be like yeah
this is the stuff everything i watch is
good i have no idea what's bad anymore
and this is why i think i relied on
reviews because i only ever watched
things that were good yeah and i feel
like the more i've just been watching
stuff and making my own opinions the
more i'm kind of enjoying the process of
then just being like
okay what do i think about that movie
not look at anything else yeah yeah it's
weird i don't know because i definitely
did feel that i'm i was so spoiled
watching everything that was quote
unquote good that was getting to the
point where i'm like all right i said
this must be i don't know this must be a
weird take i'm just like what is good
anymore i don't know
i mean i watch enough [ __ ] things for my
job
for me like there's nothing that grinds
my gears more when i watch something and
i feel like it was just a waste of time
like something that's not entirely good
but not even that bad
yeah the mediocre ones are the ones the
mediocre ones are just like i could have
done so many things at that time which
is why you would never go out your way
to watch a five or six out of ten no no
no but if you turn up in the cinema you
don't know what it is and you watch five
or six out of ten you're like no okay
but i'm not the kind of person who just
walks up to a cinema and goes i'm just
gonna watch something yeah like if i'm
at a cinema i'm there for a specific
movie if like for me to go to a cinema i
am committed to whatever i'm watching
like
movie theater for you americans out
there
because like to me yeah i get it because
if you're in the movie theater uh like
you're just you're committed to be there
and i've only ever walked out of one
movie in my life
and uh that was the live action ghost in
the show oh yeah oh yeah
and that was just because i was just
like i watched about 40 minutes and i'm
just like this is neither good nor bad
it's a waste of my [ __ ] time right
and i i like i i went there by myself as
well so i'm like no commitments i am
just going to walk out
you know i think what movies i watched
um
i watched the last duel recently do you
know the movie the [ __ ] was that all
right exactly right so so all the recent
movies yeah all i know about this movie
is that it starred adam driver and matt
damon okay that's all i knew about this
movie i knew that it was kind of based
in like the 1300s or something right
so
turns out the plot is about something uh
where there was a
famous rape case in the 1300s in france
it was kind of like unheard of that
there would be you know a court trial
around something like this yeah and then
it ended up in a duel and uh the whole
the whole movie of this thing is like
telling the perspective of each person
involved in in the in the rape right so
it's like the the woman's perspective
the guy doing the rape and then the
husband of the woman right right getting
raped and because obviously it's like
the 1300s so the rules are all like
totally [ __ ] and obviously yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
and it was it was
it was good but it was also like really
weird because it was supposed to be like
1300s france and just matt damon was
there and like an american and then not
even
is this a new movie yeah but and then
like ben affleck was there are they
doing like a french accent no no it's
just american but it was just kind of
like okay
it was the first time in my life what
i'd ever genuinely felt like a movie was
bogged down by having actors i knew like
i was like this is just like
i just i don't need to see matt david
because he can't see matt damon because
i'm watching this movie and i'm like
there could have been so many better
people who could have done this role
yeah
you know
if it was in french i wouldn't have
cared obviously it wouldn't have got the
budget and obviously you know that kind
of stuff yeah yeah but like i don't know
it felt weird because then there was
like american and then super british
dudes and then some dudes with french
accents and it was like this whole weird
thing where i was like
like i i think the movie was good but
also there was just like the casting
felt really weird yeah i didn't really
know what to think and then i did go
online and it was like 8.5 or something
and i really i was like okay i mean i
guess that makes sense but yeah
do your opinions get skewed when you see
online reviews and or like when you have
your initial opinion and then you see
the reviews and then you just do you
think your like opinion gets skewered a
bit um sometimes sometimes i'd love to
tell you i'm immune to my opinion
everyone everyone out there watching is
just like
other people's opinion do not affect me
yeah i have my opinion and that's that
and i'm just like i think for most
things it doesn't affect me but then
there are times again where like similar
to your situation where it's like i'm
not sure if i enjoyed it or not so i
need like a second appearance
back me up this is a good film right
this is a good feeling
you know and the film is very
uncomfortable and and
you know it's kind of hard to watch at
times but then i'm also like i guess
that's the point though that's the idea
it's not supposed to be fun to watch
but then i'm going to the movies to pay
for watch something and so this i was in
this weird spot where i was like this
could be a four or an eight and i don't
know which one it is yeah by like public
concern so it's one of those kind of one
of those movies
i left it thinking like okay i think it
was an eight but i just wish the casting
was better i didn't read anyone else's
reviews i just saw the score yeah i i
don't know maybe people disagree with me
on that but i was like yeah i was just
like whatever and then on the opposite
end of the spectrum i was like i'm gonna
watch james bond yeah he's like it was
like i know everything about this i've
i've read all of daniel craig's weird
ass interviews yeah you've seen that
man's interviews yeah yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is that man on
whatever the [ __ ] this man saying
that's so funny
daniel craig articles were better than
the movie
reading these articles i got like 10
times more enjoyment reading these
articles oh yeah yeah did you read the
article where he was like i kiss
everyone on set did you read this song
this article
give your homies a little smoochie no no
no no no no it wasn't just it wasn't
giving your homies a smooch it was like
oh my god i'm born james won
daniel craig and rami malik's claim the
pair kissed on jim's bonshu i'm a very
friendly guy in quotes
so who said this randy malcolm
daniel craig
alex said craig grabbed him and picked
him up after he she had a good idea for
the movie
it's so weird
yeah
it's like it's so bizarre he grabbed me
pick me up and the moment
he grabbed me picked me up and i can't
tell who initiated them the next moment
whether it was him or i but a kiss
transpired between the two of us he said
what kind of kiss he said i'm going to
say daniel craig i need to know how much
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i'm going to say that daniel craig
initiated it and i was very taken aback
he added that the kiss was he heard that
the kiss was very welcome and that at
the time he yes craig so does this make
me a bond girl
and then this is a quote from daniel
craig i kissed him all right i kissed
lots of people grace
it's like i'm a very friendly guy and i
wouldn't rank
that would anybody that would be a
terrible thing a terrible thing to do to
rank the best kisses i would i would
just how many people could i offend
terrible thousands of people
oh my god
i understand what is going on on the set
of james bond just going around to every
act to be like have i kissed you yet not
sure just go around like just frenching
people like
that's the audition process all right
you're suitable for the role
get daniel craig again
listen the stories had legs about
kissing rammy i've just been trying to
get it more legs i don't know if it's on
social media i haven't got social media
but i said i used to kiss rammy at the
end of every scene it's just like it's
just like not a big deal god almighty
just spreading the love
malik
[Music]
malik quipped i would just rush through
scenes just to get to the moment that
you would get kissed
what
what
it sounds like a [ __ ] love story
going on yeah the directors are like
damn they're really pushing through one
take wondering it was just kind of like
why don't you just like just just [ __ ]
like yeah
it was it was just such a bizarre read i
was like
what what
what is going on why are they sharing
this it sounds like an onion i love it
when i watch james bond then it was
nothing like that i watched james bond
and i would just imagine him at the end
of every scene i just imagine him just
running off and going making out with
malik
i love it i was like this is the best
article i've ever i've ever read in my
life i was laughing my ass off
there's countless articles of from
daniel craig before this movie came out
i've just like insane just losing his
mind just saying the randomist [ __ ] he
just brought up the one time he was like
he only goes to gay bars because it's
more friendly or something and i was
like what is it okay though right no no
he was saying i feel more safe there
other people won't try and start fights
with me i'm like what are you doing well
you were getting in fights at every bar
i mean he is james bond you know yeah
yeah
he's like 50 minutes
is it just like
like it's cool it's cool dude it's 20 21
bro like just it's fine right nothing's
going to be my favorite daniel craig
clip though you guys know the weekend
yeah ladies and gentlemen yeah there's
okay and there's the there's another
article where he didn't know about the
meme yeah they introduced the meme to
him yeah and he's like that's great
that's amazing
like daniel craig articles are better
than the [ __ ] movie
the article's ten out of ten the movie
was a five out of ten yeah it was kind
of sorry wait no did you watch this yeah
yeah
the time to kill was it that's how you
die time to die time to die
yeah that's fine i mean i don't know we
should do a movie set up yeah i'm not
i'm not even really like a fan of the
daniel craig james movies like any of
them i'm not saying that was good
was okay
i think it was like peaked like seen a
royale and then it was like his first
movie yeah yeah he's just well that's
good that's when they like really
reimagined james bond i was like never
really uh like a massive fan of james
bond but obviously i just feel like it's
just not as massive a franchise as it
was when you know we were growing up
when are like our parents ages yeah and
i i think like especially you said about
like the matt damon movie which i
somehow haven't heard of like remember
like back in the day if matt damon and
who else was in it adam driver and ben
affleck like like
yeah i mean these are like a-list actors
and i remember back in the day if they
were in the movie you'd [ __ ] hear
about it but nowadays i feel like movies
it's weird because movies aren't sold on
their actors anymore i feel like well no
there was a there's an amazing uh
interview at comic-con with um i've got
the name of the guys the guy who plays
uh
um the guy with iron man he's like
friend john favreau
john cheetah not john cheadle oh another
streak she gone
wait no who wait wasn't him who just
he's a superhero anthony mackie anthony
oh
that's falco falcon that's your wife
that's that's not iron man's best friend
that's that's captain america's best
friend come on
so what was the quote so
he used this formula interview at
comic-con and i came on my recommended
at one point and it was him just
basically explaining how like you know
like stallone uh schwarzenegger don't
sell movies anymore it's the superheroes
that sell movies
and nobody cares
really i mean they do care about the
actor who plays it yeah but it's not
it's not the actor who brings in that
maybe maybe
he needs to be like
yeah he needs to be like the right actor
because back in the day you could just
hire an actor or a rob
dreadful uh movie that rob downey jr did
with like it was like doctor doolittle
but like
oh yeah
yeah
right after end game yeah his first like
big movies apparently was this awful uh
dr doolittle kind of version and he was
trying to do like a welsh accent or
something yeah yeah yeah was it just
called doctor was that a reimagining of
dr doodle it was a remake yeah i think
it was a remake of thought it was like
because movies that don't need remake
doctor too little because because the
thing is yeah robert downey jr was
massive as iron man but at the same time
i think robert downey jr was just acting
robert downey jr yeah you know what i
mean why didn't he was green in sri
lanka
yeah yeah but that's because he was also
just playing a british version of
himself
you know like it's um it's like the
movie culture i feel has changed and
people care more about concepts nowadays
because like even with something like
dune
that's a massive like new movie
franchise i don't actually know any of
the actors in it even though i know
there are some famous actors in it
there's some famous actors but
yes
but like i yeah that's not the reason
you're watching dude jason mama's
probably the biggest one that's like oh
yeah
yeah yeah but that's like not the reason
you're watching so in some ways i'm kind
of i'm kind of glad that it's it's it's
straight away from the actors cell
movies not the movie like it kind of is
you know
it it means that we hopefully get
different actors but we still don't
really but there's more chance that
you'll go to watch a movie because
people say it's the concept because
stallone's in it yeah yeah yeah like i i
don't know like i was never really i
don't know if this is because like
different generation thing but i never
really cared about the actor in it no i
didn't either i mean it sold movies
i'm for the character right yeah yeah
exactly you know the performance is good
great that's good for them but it's a
bonus if it's like an actor that you
like right yeah an actor that you know
is like perfect for the role but it's
like i'm not gonna go watch i mean
there's definitely you know the only one
the only one i can think of is like a
nicholas cage movie right yeah it's like
i'll watch it because
that's like a meme right that's
something like adam sandler yeah exactly
exactly right i don't sound like the
only guy now who can like sell movies by
just being absolutely literally just
being him like he's literally like the
only guy who could like make a crew of
just [ __ ] like being like lazy yeah just
like doing it that's true yeah even then
he [ __ ] killed it uncut gems i'll say
this for like the 10 millionth time
watch that goddamn movie it's amazing do
yourself a favor you need to do
something watching yeah because like i
had this thought the other day because i
was like on on the topic of celebrity
culture i was like do you think there's
going to be someone who is going to be
as famous as michael jackson is in our
lifetime again because i feel like
probably
you think so probably i don't know i
don't think who do you think is the most
famous person right now
kim kardashian unfortunately
you know i actually googled this after i
have this thought do you know who was
ranked as num the number one most famous
celebrity well let's see
wait wait was it like isn't it like
[ __ ] whole it's a footballer probably
right no really
uh cristiano ronaldo leo no messi we're
in the top 10 though what what what's
the occupation actor an actor yeah i was
surprised
i thought i don't know what oh my god i
wish it had himself number number two
was donald trump which was not
surprising right right i think about it
but number one really surprised me male
female male male male actor hold on i
can think yeah
yeah
i didn't i didn't intend this to turn
listen to it
no it is dwayne the rock just oh yeah
okay
and i'm just like is he that famous no
he is he is he yeah he's like
internationally yeah is he isn't he like
one of the most like highest paid actors
yeah because yeah he is like fast and
furious movies are like everywhere yeah
everywhere he's also he's also one of
those actors that
looks and feels natural in like an adult
film like fast and furious but also in
like a disney film yeah you know it's
fast and fear as an adult film well i
mean compared to like moana
you know i mean say what you will but
like having a recognizable face and
figure is like yeah definitely a part of
it yeah that's true yeah and just his
name's the rock you know yeah i mean
people are going to remember that
what surprised me is that he wasn't like
he wasn't the first person to come up to
mine when i think of like a famous
person right yeah um but he is just
he's also one of those guys where you if
you say the name then you're like oh
yeah of course yeah yeah you know like
yeah he's famous it's definitely easier
when you're when you have like a name
that's super easy too yeah that's true
yeah yeah dwayne the wrong job is also a
cool name right
it's called the pain
it's more like catchy than just dwayne
johnson yeah because like especially
like traveling around the world now you
realize that people are just like
people like there's different levels of
famous depending on where you are in the
world yeah
ronaldo is like known everywhere yeah
yeah exactly football is massive except
for probably like the us right that's
probably like the biggest place they all
probably know right now they're still
right maybe do they do they i don't know
i don't know americans do you know who
cristiano ronaldo is i know at one point
david beckham was like the most like
famous person on earth yeah yeah you
don't think it's now because yeah yeah
but i swear like 10 20 years ago he was
like yeah the most famous person oh yeah
yeah yeah because like beckham phase
well it's it's weird to see how
celebrity culture has evolved right
because i'm like how i got onto this
thought was i remember i got recommended
a clip of a michael jackson concert and
it was just literally like michael
jackson's standing up on the stage
standing still and then people are just
like passing out in the crowd
it's it's insane
so there's this concert this is a really
famous concert it's on youtube right
the opening right yeah it the the lights
come on and then from from the stage
there's like a trap door that opens yeah
and michael jackson literally shoots
just like like it emerges out with some
sunglasses and he's standing there and i
swear for 10 minutes this crowd is
losing their [ __ ] there are people
like he literally just stands there like
he's like the literal clip on youtube is
called michael jackson standstill and
people pass out
and it's just like insane to think that
like he was like back in the day he was
put up to like almost god-like status i
mean i can't imagine someone today
having that kind of reaction or anyone
today having that kind of i mean i i
feel that way as well whenever i look at
you know like beatlemania clips from
like the 70s yeah yeah right people
losing their mind to the beatles right
that's bts now right
you think
i think the thing is with
i don't know i think i think bts is in
like bts fans are like oh challenge
accepted
i mean it's the i think it's the closest
thing we've had to that level of like
intensity true but i don't think we've
had anything i think though the thing is
it doesn't look as intense because a lot
of that is all online now that's true
whereas back in the during beatlemania
like if you wanted to go see the beatles
you had to go physically to go see them
i think another thing is that you just
know way more about the celebrity
nowadays because of social media and
it's like it kind of like humanizes them
more than before when your only exposure
to them was through
was through like
like news media and tv and like
interviews and stuff like that and that
was the only slice you got behind what
was what their lives were and now every
you know about everything like you know
the good and the bad like i remember
it's so weird seeing seeing like for
example chris pratt i remember when
everyone [ __ ] loved chris brown he
was like he was like the golden child
yeah
do you mean now
no
no
then suddenly and suddenly people just
started hating him i can't remember what
set it off i didn't even know why
it might have been the i remember he did
like a lot of christian remarks a lot of
people like were not like happy about
that yeah
oh okay i guess i missed that arc of
chris
i missed that luck i just like one day i
woke up and it was like it was cool to
like chris pratt and then i woke up on
another year and everyone was suddenly
here now it's cool to like chris pratt
again he's getting every right i could
be mistaken on this i know that a lot of
people got annoyed at him uh around the
time of like i think when um
james gunn got fired from yes yes yes
and like everyone from guys in the
galaxy like try to like uh like well
like openly like supporting you know
james gone yeah i think i think chris
pratt didn't really do anything and that
like kind of rub you the wrong way or he
gave some vague christian-esque
statement that people didn't really like
all right yeah i know that was around
the time when i first started seeing
staff people like didn't like chris
pratt yeah but you know i mean it's it's
all you know the internet's like that
now you can't stop hearing about chris
pratt because not only now is he married
but he's also garfield as well i can't
believe bro is he garfield he's voicing
garfield wait what yeah when did this
get announced this morning
so like so like
the real mvp here chris is asian is like
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah [ __ ] is that asian
boy this man is insane like you need a
raise oh this ancient man he better keep
him on lock man this agent
is like your agent just walked in and
was like oh by the way you're gonna be
voicing mario and garfield next up next
up you'll see it tomorrow he's voicing
groove from despicable me he's taking
over steve carrell move aside you should
notice maxwell anyway
my god
yeah like this morning especially on
twitter i was like
and also did you hear as well that uh
they're making so you know how seth
rogen is playing as donkey kong yeah
yeah donkey kong is getting his own
movie as well that's been coming seth
rogen
[ __ ] off yeah that was confirmed as well
[ __ ] off your life
unfortunately this is it was the weird
timeline i woke up to this morning
i'm like seth rogen dog killings getting
his own movie and chris pratt is
garfield what's going on with these
movies this is like the proof that we
live in a parallel universe like like
this is we've like from somehow like
we've jumped timelines and we've not
realized that we've jumped timelines do
you want the mario movie to be good
no no no no why not
i've seen i got to define good define
good yeah
i wanted to like legitimately be a
critically successful what do you think
the sonic movie was good
i actually like the scene i still
actually i like the song
i feel like you should go into like that
kind of rail okay where it's like
critically not nothing yeah
yeah i
yeah
yeah
yeah what do i want it to be i just
don't know what to think about it i
guess i just can't put my you know how
like
when you hear the sonic movie and it's
like you can kind of figure out all
right i can kind of understand where
they would go with this cast and these
characters right that makes sense yeah
with the mario thing that they've
announced so far i think the reason why
everyone's freaking out is because i was
like what the [ __ ] is this movie like
what what are they doing
what actually is this movie who's
against what we just said where where we
said celebrities can't sell a movie they
[ __ ] solve you have they said they
saw me on the mario movie you sold me
by like i'm like there is no way this
can be a movie like an actual thing
because what's so surreal about the
mario movie is that it's a [ __ ] meme
it is it is it is a [ __ ] post that got
made into reality right how is donkey
kong as seth rogen going to contribute
to this plot i don't understand because
donkey kong rarely contributes to any
[ __ ] thing in mario he's kind of just
chilling out
the one i'm personally excited for is uh
keegan
yeah
yeah how is that gonna come into this
how are they gonna introduce keegan as
toad how does that happen in the movie
i'm thinking i'm sitting here and i i
hope i hope this age is poorly or
something yeah i'm so confused and like
even now
like and then like and then the real
mario voice actors gonna cameo how how
is that to happen yeah that's what is he
just going to say it's a me mario and
mario is is like [ __ ] you mario yeah
he's not the me
is going to be like no it's a meteor
mario and like they have this weird
[ __ ] rush hour 3s stupid thing like
is that what's gonna happen i don't know
like the entire thing could be like a
new grounds parody animation from like
12 like 2010 or something you know like
an oni ng yeah yeah right
except it's a [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
reality
illumination as well which is also like
the [ __ ] like i don't i don't know what
illumination done despicable me
oh okay and that kind of those kind of
movies did they make the uh uh emoji
movie as well no that was sony okay yeah
okay sony
well they had like into the spider verse
and they were like counter back track
yeah i think it's different from
different studios and stuff yeah i mean
i think i think that was a different
studio and into the spider verse is kind
of just its own anomaly you know because
there's there's no other animated movie
i think that it's just like into the
spider verse because no such a unique
still haven't watched it and i haven't
watched it so here's the thing right i
really really really want to watch it in
the cinema and i just didn't and then
now i really want to watch it but i'm
like [ __ ] it we'll just do a dislike
i'll find a really rich friend and i'll
be like can i go to your home cinema and
can we watch into the spider verse
because i've been like holding off on it
like can we do that i don't have any
friends with a movie theater thing maybe
face clown like invite me out i'll make
one the trash taste movie
tastes movies theater let's move let's
move the trash taste studio to like
arkansas or something i bet like we
could get like a big plot of land there
yeah probably trust me
make our own theater arkansas yeah then
we can get a theater there but one
fans what are you saying yeah one thing
i'm so jealous whenever i see americans
set up their studios or their house it's
just like they've got so much [ __ ]
space well yeah if we if we paid the
amount we're paying for the studio in
america we'd have like quadruple the
space because like
like like
even even in like living in england as
well we don't get space in england as
well you know like our houses our houses
compared to americans are like [ __ ]
chinese they are bigger than japan it's
like where i put japan uk is 20 bigger
and then 80 percent well would you say
japan or tokyo because this is two two
different things even outside of you
know you'll go to the countryside in
japan right and you'll look you'll see
these like giant sprawling fields you'll
see four tiny houses just right next to
each other they didn't want any privacy
they decided [ __ ] privacy they're like
the rice fields need more room yeah
because that's what the countryside is
it's like yeah it's like 90 rice fields
but with the amount we're paying for
this studio if we were like way outside
of the church we would probably get like
at least double triple some of those
houses they're giving them away for free
yeah yeah like 100 bucks a month yeah
exactly
i mean like the housing market in japan
is like not the most healthiest thing in
the world i mean that's what happens
when you have a declining population
right yeah
yeah so so people are literally giving
away houses in some places it's
interesting because japan's government
is just like yeah it's a problem and
then i was like we're gonna do japan's
like yeah it's a problem
that's a lot of social issues in japan
actually
no they say no they they go oh it's a
problem what are you gonna do about it
like we'll make the old people live
longer yeah basically basically up the
healthcare
like their kids will stay on the
countryside right yeah right people want
to stay in the countryside will we have
a job i don't know it's really
interesting because it's one of those
problems that like
where it's you can't you can't have a
platform to campaign on being like yeah
i'll fix the problems that's going to
come in 30 years yeah
you know which is all politics i guess
really yeah this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like using your smartphone
without a case don't it couldn't be us
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but all it takes is one accident drop
onto solid concrete to make you wish you
had protected yourself nightmare fuel
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airports
anywhere your online data is not secure
what any hacker on that same network can
gain access and steal your personal data
seriously i am see [ __ ] and it actually
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack someone what just some cheap
hardware is needed a smart 12 year old
could do it and joey don't forget your
data is valuable hackers can make up to
1 000 per person selling personal info
on the dark web but luckily expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that hackers can't steal your sensitive
data it'll take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption all you
have to do is fire up the app and click
one button to get protected and you can
put it on your phone laptop tablet and
more so you can stay secure on the go do
you use expressvpn connector of course i
do every day so let's see your online
data today by visiting
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trashtaste and you can get an extra
three months for free
expressvpn.com links in the description
below wonderful back to the episode but
yeah i saw the matrix trailer as well
and i you know when when
i i guess so i'm
you you brought up the matrix joey
brought up seeing the matrix yeah i saw
the trailer for the matrix resurrections
i think it's called yeah yeah i i'm
gonna be honest with you i've watched
all the matrix movies and i cannot
remember what happened in any of them me
neither i kind of have because i
went on a stint of watching matrix clips
like for some random not the movies not
the movies the clips and i'm just like
man i think the second and third movie
were way better than what i remember
because i was watching these clips yeah
i was watching the clips um
this is just how i experience movies
nowadays god literally doesn't watch
movies watches one fifth of a movie and
decides if he likes the movie or not and
then never watches it i can't believe
we're about to live vicariously through
you watching cause like i just watched i
just watched the best parts of the
movies and the great thing about
watching the best parts of the movies is
that you get to blank out all the [ __ ]
it just makes the movie look way better
so i remember saying in our movie
episode that i don't think the matrix
has aged well at all yeah and i think i
think there was like so many little
things that i didn't um that i didn't
really understand when i first watched
the matrix trilogy right apparently the
co-director said that it was a metaphor
for being trans the whole movie series
what
really yeah well i mean the wachowski
brothers did yeah
i you know again this is this is just
something i read and i was like oh i
don't know that oh okay yeah cool but i
mean i don't know
yeah i mean what i found what i found
was really cool was how the entire world
was kind of like built like you know
like a program and i didn't realize at
the time when i watched it as a kid that
basically every character like every
character like represented a different
program or a different
uh a different subsystem of the matrix
and i'm just like oh there was so much
thought that went into this about matrix
law that just [ __ ] flew over my head
as a kid i'm just like oh cool people go
bang bang bang people yeah yeah
that's all i care about
that's that's all i cared about as a kid
and i i realized when i was like
watching these clips and like watching
videos about matrix law and like how
and what you say what's your role in our
youtube essay about why the matrix is
good and and you shouldn't care
no i watched uh i i was only about four
hours it was two hours actually it was
only about four hours thank you very
much i needed someone to tell me what to
think about the movie because
that's why i watch giggling to watch
anime
so do you think it needs a new movie do
you want a new movie of matrix i mean i
wasn't expecting it but you know what i
am curious if i were to be honest
if it makes counter happy i'm fine with
it
i think there is space for a new movie
the problem is i don't remember how the
third movie ends the third movie ends
spoiler alert uh
for a 20 year old uh yeah for a tony
orton movie with uh neo and agent smith
fighting yeah and you know there's there
they're doing like the superman [ __ ]
yeah and then agent smith like i forgot
like what he like
puts his hand into neo he becomes agent
smith and then neo dies because
and then he uh and then humans and
machines live in harmony
and uh the matrix is saved and uh that's
it it's remade and i think that's the
movie so how would you go on from that
question i i i i can't remember what the
trailer of the plot was it's just very
confusing yeah i just think there is
like because
that's what got me into it because i saw
the trailer now i remember because i was
like how are they gonna make a fourth
movie and so they got me to look into
the original trilogy this is why i got
uploads once a month
i'm like i'm like i'm like retracing my
steps to why i started watching matrix
players and it was because of the fourth
trailer and uh i think there is space
because there is space more storytelling
with different iterations of the matrix
and i think that was one really
interesting part of the matrix that was
never been able to was never explored in
the original which was this was just one
version of the matrix so there were like
there could be plenty of others and
there could be plenty of others in the
future so there's
so many ways you can so what you're
saying is it could turn into like a fate
situation
no no no no no i did not say that i did
not say that
you said there were multiple universes
multiple timelines and all i could think
of was oh it's just like it's like fate
there's a moon yeah they have a moon
oh my okay so
here's
i want to watch the movie yeah but i
understand that i have to go back and
watch the other three yeah and i don't
think you do though no really no no
i kind of want to though but i feel like
i would miss so much yeah the point of
the movie but then also re-watching the
other movies you can't not pay attention
if you it's one of those movies you look
away at your phone for one second you're
like rewind that two minutes please yeah
um i i i know yeah i do want to watch it
i just don't know it's time yeah yeah i
mean it's it was it was a different it
was like it was a different
uh experience going like revisiting the
matrix like i kind of realized how much
of an amazing character morpheus is now
and that makes me really sad that they
didn't get laurence fishbone to uh oh
yeah they didn't did that come back as
morpheus even though they got like the
main is there a reason why is i think
because they're doing young morpheus in
this one so i mean it might be might be
a plot point
he wasn't john wick was he and johnny
and john wick is he joy he's in john
wick
yeah i did like that keanu reeves
basically just looks like
it was just basically john was giving up
like like i'm going to contradict myself
to my point earlier where i said that i
don't watch movies because the actors i
yeah i will watch almost anything with
keanu reeves just because he's such a
delight to watch like you guys just have
he always you can tell he loves it it's
also cool to think that in real life
he's also really chill yeah yeah you
know i know it's like the thing that you
do when you're when you're on the
internet to just adore keanu reeves but
like legitimately like when he's on
screen i love watching him yeah yeah
i genuinely feel that he loves every
second of performing oh yeah and it's
just a delight to watch yeah absolutely
sometimes it's just nice to see someone
who loves something that they do
like let's see who's someone who loves
their job you know i don't know it's
it's it's it's the little things in life
you know even when he's doing these
characters you can just tell like
through it but yeah yeah i don't know
why i don't know how you can do that but
it works but i don't know why but keanu
reeves seems like the kind of guy who
would like collect much of the movies
he's like that kind of guy right he's
like dude i've got this john week action
figures [ __ ] sick john wick is like
some of my most enjoyable theater
experiences like every single time i've
gone to watch in the movie theaters i've
just had such a [ __ ] delight i've
only seen the first one honestly
the first one as well yeah please watch
the other two they're so fun
really good movies let's see the episode
watch some work just go watch sean
walked on much right now yeah do you
know what realization i had the other
day as as you guys are talking about
movies yeah so um i haven't been
watching movies recently i've gone back
to being i've gone back to watching
anime now
what i know i know i i finished i
finished my i finished my seasonal video
and i'm just like i feel like continuing
some of these shows out of my own
volition what did you watch oh what did
you do i just i just i just had this
realization the other day uh i like it
one that yeah i actually like anime and
number two so i finished watching some
of these episodes and i'm just like
huh i don't have anyone to talk to this
about oh
everyone in my life around me doesn't
watch anime anymore and i'm just like am
i the last [ __ ] who still
watches anime
if it's not on netflix connor doesn't
touch it listen i'll watch it if it's
off netflix yeah just begrudgingly do it
i'll be like for [ __ ] sake because
okay
it's so weird because like when me and
sydney started our relationship we'd
like the start of our relationship was
like we'd watch like a new show or
something yeah between us like every
every you know every time we had some
free time and now i'm just like honey
you wanna watch an anime and she's like
no show me put on a shitty horror movie
that's what i want to watch let's let's
put on 90 day fiance and i'm just like
get that japanese [ __ ] out of here
ew
and i'm just like okay so i started my
youtube journey having no friends around
me who watched anime then i found too
many too many friends who watch anime
and i'm just like every time i hung out
with friends everyone around me watch
anime
and then now i moved to japan started an
anime podcast um i'm dating a girl who
or oh i'm going to get married to a girl
who was a big weeb an anime fan and no
one for rounding [ __ ] watches anime
what the [ __ ] is going on
i've i've literally looped back to where
i started off at
those who don't learn from history
yeah it is the cycle of a weeb it is so
surreal now though that i know more
people who've watched anime and who are
like heavy anime fans but are now just
like no just like no just like more
integrated into like the weeb culture or
like the wider anime culture without
actually watching anime it's it's so
weird you know that it's like the floor
is and it's like the meme it's like the
floor is watching anime i'm like
literally doing everything but yeah
i'm reading like books yeah recently i
feel like what you've been reading books
books with no pictures no drawing i
would talk about it because i haven't
finished them
i'm reading a few of them what kind like
story books information like fictional
nonfiction
autobiography yeah
i'm halfway through one that's really
good right now okay okay it's about
japan and it's really good i'll talk
about it when i'm done
something's something's like okay but
it's like literally the floor is anime
and i'm like [ __ ] jumping in the air
i feel like we are in the matrix right
now
you know you know all the signs you look
for to to like to like see if the world
you're living is fake i feel like i i
feel like there's enough going on around
me right now but i'm just like
we're in the matrix right now okay all
right stop the simulation i know
i know this okay get me out get me out
of read a book i'm gonna kill myself
because i'm in a simulation
i watched actually i didn't tell you
about this i watched an anime on the
plane back to the uk okay i watched
eight episodes and i stopped i was very
angry yeah i watched was it 81 87 was
86.86
bro it was [ __ ] was it it was bad you
didn't like it i thought it was better
i've heard really good things about it
bro it was like literally everyone i
know it's all about it i like it what do
you like about it i mean i just like the
concept it's been so long since we've
seen like i i feel like it's the closest
we've had to like one of these
mega shows that i watched growing up at
least where it was like two nations
going against each other and then
there was some mystery going on and you
didn't know you didn't like the mystery
i was so bored by the mystery i was like
okay whatever and then the whole time
don't look at me i haven't seen the
whole time the whole time they were
doing the whole thing of like
like
you know you know obviously obviously
racism is bad right i get it but when
they like spoon feed it to you like
racism bad huh huh it comes here yeah
it's like oh racism and it's like all
right i get it right so it's like it's
like such an unnuanced take about it
that i was like okay all right we get it
i i get that yeah i was just like i was
so bored by it i was like i get it all
right
i don't need you to tell me that this is
like this is the story like this is yeah
and i should feel sad
so they were like over explaining it to
me it felt i mean it was very
it was very much put in your face i mean
the entire thing was basically based
around world war ii it was kind of like
nudging like huh huh
like it was the whole time watching it i
was just so bored and i was like and the
whole mystery aspect to it i was not
enjoying so actually should we roughly
explain what the plot of this show is
first sure so
what do you remember okay so i'm very
very curious it's been a month it's been
two months since i watched this and it
was on a plane i love it when connor
tries to describe banana yeah there is a
main emcee who is a everyone in this
world right is in this beautiful
homogenous society everyone is the same
has the same hair color and same you
know everyone looks like everyone is
lights it's aryan bro they're all ariel
that's literally what they're trying to
do
and so they're in this world and
everything's perfect and they keep doing
this [ __ ] stupid thing where they're
like and it was just like it was so
obvious what they were trying to do
where it was just not having i was just
like okay we get it they were like every
single day they'd be like we have zero
casualties in this wall isn't that
amazing zero casualties zero casualties
and the whole point of it is that they
have these mechs that are fighting and
they're piloted by the other people who
are not the perfect race right and uh
they make them fight in the max and uh
they have they have uh yeah
and they have these they have these met
these mech like captains these are the
captains that talk to the peasants god
forbid they have to talk to them right
yeah somebody has to talk to them
in this world and our main main
protagonist guess what she's sympathetic
to the the presence as they say i'm
calling them i don't know what i've got
what they're called
so i'm running with it now they're
called the person
now so obviously she's sympathetic and
she starts to become friends with them
right oh turns out these these other
race of people they're they're they're
just normal human beings who'd have
thought you know and it's just like it's
like all right okay come on man yeah
like come on it does sound pretty dumbed
down so like it's like
it's like if you i don't know like a
disney movie take on it you know yeah it
was just so
it was like dr seuss like cat in the hat
level of talking about right i was just
like sarah oh we get it come on
21st century now we get more nuanced
takes about this i'll tell you like a
perfect analogy which will i think
you'll understand jerry it feels like
again a robuchi show without being
written by genorabuchi
so yeah okay explain that to me i get
one exactly like okay okay you get it
now you get it okay yeah okay now
explain that to me okay so
the guy who wrote psycho pass he wrote
madoka magicka and
psychopaths i i thought was amazing and
like a really good take on the the whole
societal aspect of that but like this
just felt like yes that's what he means
yeah it's like a show that's written by
ghana
but not worse yeah yeah but like not as
nuanced
do you think it's bad
do you think my my opinions on this i
mean i i think i i think i think yeah i
think yeah you actually have the correct
opinion where it's like very spoon-fed
into you the yeah like racism is bad and
that's never why i kind of liked it i i
kind of like more
i kind of more gravitated towards like
the mystery aspect of just like because
one thing one big thing you missed is
they're at war so this nation is at war
with another nation right i could figure
out that roughly what was going on yeah
yeah and and the other nation
has robots that are completely
autonomous like they they have technical
they have a technology that is way more
advanced and they have ai robots that
they're fighting against uh except the
nation that we're following has human
robots right right uh so
apparently the nation is like i can't
remember the exact details because i'm
not up to date but apparently the nation
has a time limit right and after this
time limit is over
then the robots are going to shut down
because there's no one actually telling
these robots to fight i don't know if
they like heard about y2k probably
yeah but but like i was i was more like
what drew me to this was more the
mystery aspect and more like the
character dynamics between the main girl
and the and the group itself i agree but
at times the character dynamics did feel
real predictable and stale for me yeah
it was just kind of like i i wanted to
know more about the enemy and i want to
learn more about the mystery but
everything else was such a slog to sit
through yeah that i was just like is it
maybe because it's a concept that you've
already seen in anime before it could be
there but it could also just be like i
just didn't feel like although the
mystery aspect was quite good all the
other aspects didn't really entice me
personally
you know and also i was on a plane so it
was the choice of like i can try and get
some sleep here or i can continue
watching the show and it was really
struggling every episode i kept going on
i kept thinking it's really good i know
it's not a good sign when you have to
choose between watching this
i really wanted to pick up the pace like
it was really like taking its [ __ ]
time and they really one thing i agree
on it they really like wanted to show
that the main character was sympathetic
but like it was obvious she was
sympathetic and they just kept doing
things to show that she was sympathetic
over and over again and i was just like
i get it yeah we get it we all know we
get it there's lots of sympathetic
gameplays out there
it's
it was just so frustrating watching the
show where they just had the same copy
and paste like action where she would
talk to someone they'd be like oh don't
talk to the peasants and then she'd be
like but i like them and then dude
should literally have this conversation
with everyone yeah okay maybe that would
happen in real life the situation was
real but it was just so boring they had
to show it every goddamn time we get it
it's not normal though i i i also think
it was bad timing that this came off uh
came out after attack on titan which is
like i think a way better yeah
way to show that's some of the themes
that 86 was showing that's
i think i think our attack on titan was
kind of like a master class in that
sense it's like it took aspects of
attack on titan and weirdly code geos in
some sense with the whole britannian and
all that yeah yeah yeah and didn't
really land it with any of them for me
personally like i didn't feel like it
nailed it but i got a second season so
clearly there must have been one
the second season is like the second
half of the story so it's it's kind of
more like just a continuation yeah yeah
i've only just heard good things about
it so yeah we spoke about anime okay
okay
we've got more anime whatever you want
yeah
why because it looks edgy it looks fun
oh it is edgy i've read it it looks dumb
and fun i've heard this i've heard the
ending of that is like really bad though
yeah yeah in terms of like but it looks
fun it looks like it is [ __ ] like it
looks like the high rise invasion [ __ ]
like it looks like it's bad but also is
that what you look for nowadays you know
i'm i'm trying not to be picky with
anime because if i'm going to be picky
i'm going to be like joey i'm not going
to watch anything yeah pretty much
because joey she always read all this
[ __ ] yeah but i haven't read this so i'm
like i need to just stop reading about
stuff too much and just pick something
and watch it yeah but then i did that
with 86 and i hated it
i mean
that's a give-and-take but that might
happen with platinum
yeah but but then i feel like if i've at
least done that i can then at least if i
get to eight episodes and i stop i
probably have more to say than if i
watched 12 episodes and be like eh yeah
i mean i have more to think and i have
more to say about it
and then i can go on our anime podcast
and talk about it why don't you watch
like something like i don't know
komi-san well why don't we do why don't
we do a thing where we all enjoy
we should do an anime review like once a
month where we all have to watch one
different anime and present it like a
book club oh that's so much effort
joey's
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's funny because people will like
people we have like 95 of viewers who i
swear i like i get bored when they talk
about anime yeah and this five percent
viewers are like i hate there and talk
about it yeah i [ __ ] hate them i call
themselves the anime podcast because i i
[ __ ] joke i feel like i feel like our
viewers have become like everyone around
me which is everyone everyone wasn't
ex-animated oh yeah and now everyone
just finds himself watching anything but
anime yeah it's it's it's so it's so i i
have noticed that i think the episodes
we talk about anime i think are perform
worse than the ones we talk about normal
stuff some people don't like it but it's
weird because the clips perform better
yes
i mean i mean it's because
i don't let the [ __ ] viewers decide
what to talk about i talk about what i
want to talk about you know
it's it's weird that yeah it's it's
weird that i mean it's not weird because
people want people want us i'm sure to
talk about certain shows and certain
series um because that's just going to
perform better in a short lifespan but
as a whole yeah people just want to hear
us talk [ __ ] and uh chat about what's
been happening in their lives which uh
right now has been not so much because
then it's moving yeah i've been moving
and it's it's it's almost done okay it's
it's almost done
it's almost done it's never almost done
you think it's done right okay i think
it's done and then there's something
else that pops up all all right how do
you how did you guys decide how you want
to decorate your rooms
uh
okay you know the hottest i'm gonna
sound like a [ __ ] robot right now but
i'm just like i look at a blank canvas
right i don't know i i know i'm meant to
show my personality and i'm just like
what do i show how do i show personality
give me a blank space i have no idea
what
i did right in my head i had like all
right i've got all these jojo posters
that's a must that's going somewhere on
the wall i've got these big ass walls
all right so then i know that's going
there so then
i kind of have to figure out what goes
in between the posters or whatever goes
around yeah and then it kind of starts
to kind of form yeah and then i'm like
okay here's what i want i want
soundproofing i want uh i want carpet i
want soundproof squares so i have an
idea of stuff i want yeah and then it's
kind of putting it together and then
thinking okay how would it look
like that if you know my old room it was
like i want this thing on the wall
that's it i want posters of this there's
that and then yeah so for me the problem
is is that my room and the rest of my
house is designed by two different
people
my room is yeah but your room still
looks good yeah my my room is good but
like the way we the way myself and aki
think about interior design is
completely like on the opposite end of
the screen would you decorate your
bedroom if
if you lived alone
yeah really what would you decorate it
with no i don't know i i i i've never
decorated my hair i've never done which
is which is why it's so [ __ ]
difficult for me right because the way i
approach into you wait are you going to
decorate your bedroom oh yeah no oh no
my office sorry all right so yeah
yeah yeah
same kind of deal where my approach to
interior design is my same approach i
have with like engineering it's all
about practicality and that's just not
good for interior design
i'm just like i i know because here's
here's my biggest problem with
trying to fill up my room right now in
my office is i know what looks bad
but i don't know how to make it look
good
see because like if you were if you if
you're an engineer when it comes to
interior design i'm like a programmer
where it's like
if white wall equals true fill white
wall with something
it's like that's it it's like it's like
there's no like there's no like opinion
of like oh maybe i should put something
here it's like no if there's a space on
my wall i'm gonna find something to fill
it up
yeah i one thing that's good about
living in japan is that japan is
extremely focused on practicality yeah
of like everything in your house yeah
everything has to be practical yeah so i
kind of took a lot of that in mind when
i made my office i i'm going to make an
office tour video at some point in my
main channel where i just go through
everything that i did in the office
because i think it's really i think i
did i'm really happy with my office it
took me goddamn forever though it's also
easy views it's all yeah
but also i want to talk about it because
it took me goddamn forever so i want to
get some value out of it two [ __ ]
weeks just to soundproof the [ __ ]
room
but
i think it's really easy to decorate a
room in japan when you can think more on
like practical sides of things like
you're like okay i want this here like i
want all my anime figures yeah but i
don't want i don't want them in just
like a cabinet like a glasswarm because
i want to be able to move it so i can
access the cupboards behind it but i
don't want it on the wall with all the
posters it'll block them so it's kind of
like all right so there's like 10 000
things you got to consider but you're
just trying to like compute them all but
then at some point you just got to do
something and then see how it looks
because i hope you didn't waste it yeah
because because that's that's like as
i've just established i hate wasting
time and i'm just like i just want
something that looks good i just don't
know how to make it look good without
just trying it out what if what if what
if i like rearrange all my furniture
after i've just spent all this time
building it and like you know it's doing
my chest
and then it just looks [ __ ] what if it
just looks [ __ ] because like i'm i have
a bunch of like anime merch and like i
just i just don't know how to make it
look good like i've tried putting my
anime figures on like a shelf or
something and i don't know why i just
don't think
having a bunch of anime figures on the
shelf looks good for my for my aesthetic
i say this what i said it was all this
[ __ ] but i think it works for
aesthetically yeah and uh
i don't know if we came to this by luck
or if it just you know okay so so the
way that archie does which i think is
kind of genius is that what she does is
when we first moved in right i was like
i'm gonna do my room you do the rest of
the house because you clearly have a
better sense of it than i do so what she
does is she took photos of the empty
room right and then she would go into
photoshop and literally just photoshop
in different things that she was
thinking about to like move it around
and if it looks good then she buys it
yeah and puts it exactly where she
envisioned it to be yeah and and because
then you know yeah what it looks like
before you bought it like it's kind of a
big brain buy what you need measure it
yeah because it measures
one thing i've like noticed around anime
merch now now that i'm like trying to
make my room actually look cool so a lot
of anime merch just looks really tacky
yeah
and i didn't like i didn't realize this
until now that i've moved to japan and
we've got like some cooler things but
like i was like maybe i'll try putting
some wall scrolls up and now like
even wall scrolls just look like
yes i've graduated from wall scrolls yes
hello i have been to an anime convention
that is that that is the look when you
put up wall scrolls now
i've never understood the appeal of wall
scrolls i'll be honest with you i i
they look [ __ ]
i mean i did because they like they're
like you know like posters you can get
them framed yeah they look so clean so
so like symmetrical as well so beautiful
yeah and then the nice glass panel or
plastic whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah and
then you got this like poorly printed
piece of paper with two plastic scrolls
the top and the bottom and it's never
like
i liked it at the time but then when i
learned about like framed stuff yeah
that's when i was like oh but the thing
right like those jojo posters that i
have yeah they're thirteen dollars yeah
poster obviously it's in japan right so
yeah yeah and then the frame is like 12
bucks yeah that's like 25 bucks for a
clean ass massive like really high
quality that's cheaper than a lot of
schools
like sometimes 30 bucks yeah we're
talking like even the a4 ones it's not
20 bucks
they're always like they always don't
look as good like the print is never as
clean like i don't know man i just i
don't see a wall yeah i'm i'm past the
wall scroll phase as well which is why i
like i i had wall scrolls in my old
office and i'm just like this just looks
tacky but i don't know how to uh i don't
know what i want to replace it with wall
screen and now now now i'm going through
that problem where i have to figure out
what i want to replace it with like i
have like
it's it's so it's just live in japan
it's so energy that you can get these
because like four prints i think i've
done like one cool thing with my office
right because i have like i have like a
few cool anime merch and i'm just like
what if i just put this all in a glass
case and i so i bought like a uh like a
glass case which is like a four
four component glass case
you know i filled up like the top one
was the gingivito bag that uh that i got
um the second one was like all the anime
watches that i've got as well third case
was all the wine
um or the wine equipment or the anime
wine equipment that means you've
collected and the fourth case is going
to be for
the slam dunk air jordans that i found
on yahoo auction oh yeah and i i put it
up and i'm just like damn this looks
awesome yeah and then i realized that's
like 1 100th of the entire [ __ ] room
[ __ ]
that means you got to start collecting
more stuff and i'm just like oh it looks
cool but like it's like compare like
putting it next to everything else it
just looks so empty now that one tenth
of my room looks
right
there people when they rob your house
man they're going right for that cat
the entire
manitoba wealth is stored in that one
like you've been collecting jojo figures
or jojo [ __ ] merch i'm just like this
is this is like this is how my
collection starts yeah it starts with
one cabinet yeah oh my gosh yeah
no i i i bought one of those um i didn't
buy a glass cabinet i want to be able to
move it because it's blocking my
cupboards so i bought one on wheels that
i can just kind of like shove out the
way oh yeah well one thing i definitely
underestimated was how heavy glass is oh
yeah yeah extremely so yeah
why
why what made you
okay why why did you learn this what
made you realize okay because glass
heavy because
my point was that glass was heavy and i
did not like it did not i didn't think
it was heavy i didn't like the [ __ ]
glass i didn't think about this okay i
don't think about this [ __ ]
wait i think everyone knows glasses
because water is wet
i i get because like one big issue i've
had with living in the house now is that
you have to carry things upstairs and
luckily enough my office is on the
ground floor because i have the choice
between mine being on the ground floor
and mine being on the top floor and i'm
just like i want a glass case
obviously yeah and i'm just like once i
got the glass case delivered
i was just like was glass always as
heavy
yes yes
because
i don't know how i was meant to carry
this upstairs if i needed to but thank
god i did it
glass in japan is really [ __ ] heavy
yeah
so that's so that was my story gaunt
discovers sorry
hey man i picked up this metal thing i
was like [ __ ] metal is kind of happening
oh damn damn okay [ __ ] yeah that was one
thing definitely when i was designing my
office where i realized i thought i had
a lot of stuff but then i realized that
a lot of it was stuff that was on my
wall that were things like posters and
wall scrolls that i was like you know
what
maybe it's time to change it up so yeah
so then i got really picky with what i
would put on the walls right so now i've
got like you know my gingivito bag i've
got the [ __ ] skateboards i've got the
you know my youtube play button and
stuff like that you know stuff that is
more limited and like extravagant
yeah and then i realized oh i actually
don't have a lot of stuff that is
actually of value right right and uh
yeah and then i went on this like crack
binge of buying expensive [ __ ] now uh
now i have the reverse problem where i
have too much stuff now so i have yeah
your room is just like the weebhaven you
know my my room is i have somehow i
don't know how when it happened but i've
turned into like a snobby art collector
when it comes to life
i think i'm going through that stage
yeah well i haven't got that yet i'm
just like jojo just give me jojo's like
every time i go to an exhibit now i'm
just like so where are the expensive
paintings
[ __ ] the mugs
[ __ ] the t-shirts [ __ ] the mugs
i don't want your [ __ ] figures
anymore don't want the posters don't
want the [ __ ] wall scrolls no i don't
want any [ __ ] give me the paintings give
me the cool shirt where's the limited
[ __ ] yeah exactly right how can i frame
yeah what can i what can i display the
glass box we're gonna do the anime
figure special at some point you guys
are saying this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i love figures still yeah jojo no i'll
i'll you know i'll walk into like a
figurine shop and i'll be like so were
there more than a hundred of these made
i don't want it wow give it a little
[ __ ] because your privilege is showing
does this come with a certificate of
authenticity
the thing about figures is that you just
need a [ __ ] ton of it before it looks
any good otherwise it just it's it just
looks a little bit tacky because it just
it's it's too small to be a centerpiece
but it needs to occupy like some space
right yeah and it just it just looks i
don't know it unless you have like a
really really massive figure it does to
me it doesn't like it's
but even then like a really really big
figure can still look a little tacky
depending on where it is that's why i've
like cause of cause i have that like
massive berserk figure oh yeah you do
and i'm still to this day trying to
figure out where to put it because it's
like everywhere i've like envisioned it
putting it in my room it just doesn't
look right for some reason and i realize
it might be because i need to have it
next to a bunch of other figures yeah
but the problem is my figure shelf is
like tucked away in a corner so i can't
put it yes i'm like well [ __ ] i have to
like put this like [ __ ] in the living
room or something like coffee table
coffee table yeah
yeah
is this like that [ __ ] what's that
word that's used to describe how the
energy of a room is dictated by
feng shui yeah yeah i'm trying to figure
out the feng shui with my giant bazooka
yeah
like as a kid i'm just like this is
stupid that they're like you could just
put things and it doesn't matter now
i've realized well my mood is affected
by how my room looks and i'm just like
why is this something i wouldn't go that
far personally for me i'm like
feng shui though it does get pretty
ridiculous at times yeah yeah well
it's like you'll get bad luck
some of that is ridiculous but i don't
know even like my bedroom because
like i sleep better now because our
bedroom is orientated differently from
my old bedroom
and i just realized oh it's just because
of where it is in relation to where the
window is and i'm just like
it wasn't before huh was it no not near
a window last time no it wasn't it was
like on the opposite side of the window
because i because that's yeah i mean
that yeah that probably
generally i think seeing like outsiders
make your brain happy yeah
normally your brain like that yeah like
that yeah for me like because back back
then i was just like where can the bed
take up the most efficient amount of
space
right in that corner right away from the
window yeah
you have room to put it in the middle
you put it in the middle right but then
that's like that's like a big brain
saying like i have space yeah yeah
exactly that's a flex
the other side of the beds i don't even
need them
nothing needs to go there i'm gonna put
the bed in the middle yeah yeah i know
it's weird this is the first time i've
actually like try to think about this
rather than just like going forward men
discovers interior designs yeah man
discovers materials i was like oh man i
got more space on my wall guess i'll buy
more jojo prince yeah right
i'll buy double so now i have double the
jojo prince on my wall
but i've got like a nice really cool
wall of jojo it's really nice yeah
whatever you done with like the rest of
your
merch that you built up at your place uh
jojo yeah it's all on one like four
shelf rack all right managed to place it
and then i put like the anti-earthquake
things and the figures that uh would
fall over oh so yeah that's uh i managed
to somehow get it all in but then i've
got a bunch of other stuff in other
cupboards that i can't like display like
i have like
uh a really big wooden oak box
filled with the jojo ties
separate and like neat and presentable
but there's no way to put it because
like yeah i don't know i can't put on
the floor it's the jojo ties you can't
go on the floor you're insane
lose its value exactly i own 14 or 15
something jojo literally every jojo thai
that's evident
there's like 24 oh really and uh i have
all of the ones from part four which is
12 ties in total holy [ __ ] i think it's
12.
so there's 12 ties from part four and i
think there's like eight or something
from par five right i didn't buy all of
them from part five so you you know like
when are you a kid when you see that
documentary about that guy or girl who
would collect like barbie doll and ken
dolls you become that just with jojo man
i have not don't you dare
you no because there's four fast forward
to like 50 years they would go around
they would dress up like ken and be like
i'm ken and they'd be like please call
you literally you're gay
you're a [ __ ] joker
oh come on that's dude it's like the
only piece of dress this is the meme
where it's like we are not the same you
wear ken outfit i wear jojo's suit we
are not the same
god wipes his ass i i pressure wash my
ass we are not the same gun don't
compare right don't compare me to those
[ __ ] people who cosplay we are not
the same i wear drip they wear outfits
it's not the same wearing one suit
everywhere you go does not count as drip
everyone looks good
suit's gone everyone everyone looks good
in a [ __ ] everyone looks good in a
suit not no no they don't no they don't
bro no they don't you'd have to do
something like really really bad to [ __ ]
up looking good in the suit yeah you
could you could do it you do it now
let me think about that
look bad in general i guess
just be really ugly just get a bad
fitting suit but uh if you're gonna get
one too long too short yeah yeah or your
dad's suit that's pretty much the union
yeah yeah yeah we're dancing but if it's
fitted then everyone looks good yeah
i guess
yes
i don't want to concede this point right
because i'm then i'm i'm
by this point because i can't remember
someone did like someone did like an
annie tuba drip tier list or something
oh yeah um i can't remember who it was i
remember you were like did one right i i
don't i don't think it was moon because
whoever whoever this person
whoever this person was like put connor
in like s tier and i'm just like conor
does not deserve to go and [ __ ] sto
drip he just wears one [ __ ] jojo soon
cause everyone calls it a day
everyone is blinded by the jojo that is
not drip
i'm sorry they should be it's a good
suit it looks if everyone had a jojo
suit everyone would be an st well then
everyone should get a jojo
that's not drip just waiting i want to
start a charity service to give everyone
a jojo suit to move you down the drip
tier corner that's how much i care about
this [ __ ]
i saw that
i'm going to come back in a few weeks
with more drafts i saw that serialist
video and when they put connor on st
because of the jojo suit i'm like this
man literally is in an st we're wearing
an emu like shirt i'm like
how the [ __ ] i'm gonna say you're gonna
tell me the same [ __ ] emmy shirt that
he wears on like every other week of
trash days puts him in st right now
i'm leaving like i got [ __ ] beat here
compared to this one
are you this person but you are bt drip
man get off my ass here don't talk no
what's worse is that i was also sd but i
worked for my [ __ ] like i actually have
like a wardrobe full of [ __ ] and i get
beaten by one jojo suit which i also
have yeah which we all [ __ ] own you
should get we should get five then
should we go and then we'll talk
you have one jojo i have five we are not
the same standard of drip is so low
that's what i learned yeah
because it's because you know i'm not
normally salty but i'm that day i was
salty
this is my confirmation that weebs do
not have drip yeah
every time i post pictures in the jojo
soup the perfect soup factory the maker
of the soup posts it to their instagram
do they actually yeah
i couldn't believe it at least twice
they've done it and i was like oh okay
cheers they're like look look this is
drip yeah see the makers of the suit
agree i i should be i am i am drip i
don't think they're
both made the suit i don't think they've
been reposting it because they think
it's drip i think they're reposting it
because they [ __ ] made it no no no
they're reposting because they're like
[ __ ] man
they're like this post got viral yeah
we might wear daiso socks and put it up
on an instagram post i'm sure daiso
they won't say this is drip they'll say
thank you for buying a [ __ ] 100 yen
socks all right let's see it let's watch
it happen then joe all right
well no i'm not going to because i don't
why not no no no no no no
we should buy you a pair [ __ ] daiso
socks it's all about the family it's all
about the it's all about the [ __ ]
family oh you're wearing it now it's all
about the family monsters
we talked about this before i don't know
so joey came to me one day and they were
like have you worn family socks before i
found family mart socks which is a
comedian store obviously in japan yeah
no why would i wear family with family
mart socks because they're amazing and
then they were like the most comfortable
socks on earth and i was like all right
okay so one of my one of my gaijin
friends living here like told me about
this like revelation being like have you
heard he came to me like [ __ ]
jehovah's witnesses like have you heard
of the family master socks it's like no
please do tell them and they're like
yeah they're really they're like i think
like 400 yen three four it's like three
four bucks right for a pair of socks and
i was like
how how good could a four dollar pair of
socks be at a convenience store of all
places yeah wore it
felt like i was floating bro
literally and then i was like i have to
tell i was like
yeah yeah yeah
you go
you gotta turn into a like a jehovah's
witness yeah i was converted he starts
preaching to me about this i was around
his house right i was around his house i
was playing mahjong and he started
preaching to me i'm just like it's just
just [ __ ] socks joey yeah aki comes
back with like five pairs of socks and
goes yeah i'll give you one for free i'm
like i don't need this it's a pair of
literally the guy giving the bible
just give it a go
what am i going to do with this
and i remember
i i got home and i put it put it in the
way in the corner and i remember we had
a trash taste recording the other day
and i hadn't done my washing the day
before and so i opened my drawer
empty sock drawer except for the one
family mask sock and they always it was
just it was just staring me in the face
and i'm just like
oh fine i'll wear the family mart socks
and like um there's this one scene from
rick and morty where rick uh where rick
gives morty like the perfectly flat
piece of land right do you remember that
scene i think so i can't remember where
it's like perfectly flat and morty's
like oh what is this all it's just
perfectly fine he steps on it and he
literally starts coming right here
and i was just like
i was like oh it's just [ __ ] socks
how could this kaku how good could this
be and i put it on and i'm just like
oh it fits so snuggly oh it's
it's it's hugging my feet what is what
is this feeling it's what is this cotton
it's so soft
it's like it's like i'm walking on sheep
right now what is this and i answer and
i text joey i'm just like
[ __ ] you
and i was like i have done it i have
converted it i don't know why it feels
so smooth and so silky smooth on your
skin i can't wear any other songs
it feels like a thousand kisses on your
feet my my favorite pair of socks
i bought two years ago yeah it's from
lawson's
i'm telling you they do a black pair of
socks and they are like the cleanest
socks i own are they as good as the
family master i think they're better i
doubt i you've got to try it out i
bought these socks right for two years
i've been washing them
with the family mark gospel right now
they have not they have not lost their
like firmness they haven't worn out at
all you know sometimes you get socks
they go crinkly and they go hard after a
while when you wash them because they've
been used so much these socks [ __ ]
warriors bro they're like day one they
look no different these socks are
amazing not me mad brother he's just
lost his way he's lost his way we will
guide him to the right direction you
guys give me a pair of family model i'll
give you guys a pair of the lawson's
black
okay you'll see
a trash case uh sock trunk
you'll see you'll see these socks
it's it's it's so insane because i
remember walking into our family marts
uh in tokyo the other day and they
literally had a table just for the
family mart socks by themselves which
just shows how far the gospel has spread
that they've like literally got a table
front and center in the combination
yeah that's because they're probably
always sold out yeah like every i i
think i've been to about four or five
different family mods after i first
tried the socks and i was like i have to
get more so i was like scouting around
tokyo i swear for the first four or five
family martial they they're all sold out
i'm curious what made you buy them in
the first place it's it's just like a
thing that started with like gaijins
living in japan but like like one yeah
one of the foreigners that was living
here like posted on twitter about
like trying out these family milestones
and then it kind of just spread like
wildfire from yeah and then it made its
way to me yeah it's the it's the socks
and the pumpkin spice latte
yeah yeah that's right that's right yeah
what was pumpkin spice latte got to do
with this starbucks
oh because pumpkin spice lattes in spa
pumpkin spice latte has only just now
become really massive in japan because
of the gaijins
and i guess the same thing happened with
the family mod socks and so everyone was
like all right i mean it's only four
bucks i'll try it out yeah and then the
gospel spread
and i'm like this is i'm pretty sure
this is how religions stuck
through songs
one person says it's good and then
they're the restless shock at the time
religion spread
this episode is sponsored by honey you
know how these podcast ads go we read a
spiel blah blah blah blah that's in the
script as well by the way and then we
give you a promo code or a discount and
then that's the end of it but this time
it is different gentlemen because this
is an ad for honey
and a honey air doesn't just give you
one promo code a honey ad gives you
millions of promo codes that's right
millions of promo codes in one ad read
send it to me all right so when you shop
honey will automatically fill in the
promo code box for you at checkout but
it won't just fill it in with one code
one code it'll dump a ton of codes in
there why not every code it can but i
only know zero codes joey it knows more
than zero cards oh my god then it tests
them in seconds to see if one gives you
a discount and plus honey knows where to
look for promo codes that are hard to
find on your own guys when i was buying
your christmas present spoiler alert i
might have used honey to get myself a
bit of a discount cheap [ __ ]
so get all the promo codes honey can
find at joinhoney.com trash taste that's
honey.com tracks taste links in the
description below back to the episode
[ __ ] you guys back to the episode
episode back to the episode going back
on the topic of watching stuff though um
so
as i have been watching anime again
um
i wanted to know if you have had the
same experience where do the subtitles
actively distract you now from like
what's going on in english yeah if you
have english subtitles on
sometimes i can turn off the brain part
the part of my brain that's trying to
listen to the japanese yeah i can just
ignore that because like i yeah because
like i
this was the first time i started
watching anime for my video and of
course i turned on subtitles because i
had to understand what was going on yeah
because i've been watching anime
as for like a long period of time
without subtitles and it was so weird
turning it back on because it like
actively
i i actually dislike it now it actively
distracts me from what's going on
any anime with subtitles now i'm trying
not to you know become next level i'm
i'm like trying to watch as much anime
without subtle subtitles on as i can
because like what i've realized is that
it actually it actively hurts your
language learning process if you have
english subtitles on well or at least
here's here's the way to understand yeah
here's the way i see it right because
say you have like a japanese sentence or
hear a japanese sentence and you want
the english translation of that
if the if the translator for the
subtitle is doing their job
they would have translated what they're
saying into natural english so that it
sounds natural yes whereas when i'm when
i'm trying to learn japanese and i'm
trying to process the japanese in my
head
what i've read in the subtitles and
what's being said are like are the same
things
it's different like i would actually
like i realized this where i think it
would be more useful for me
if i had google translated subtitles
than than an actual like professionally
translated subtitle right because
because when i'm going back and i'm
trying to understand something and i
read the official translation i'm just
like well yeah that that and i you know
i do my work to translate it i'm like
yeah that's what's being said but that's
not how i think about that sentence
being heard in my brain but that's also
like the problem right is that i think
at the end of the day like so much of it
is nuanced because grammatically it's
just so different yeah a lot of it is
just completely i've read some subtitles
where it's just been completely lost in
translation because there are just some
things
some phrases and ways of saying a
sentence and the way of describing
something that is so specifically
japanese yeah that if the sub if the
translator tries to translate it without
the translator notes
to explain it yeah then it just becomes
like
it becomes so nuanced to the point that
it almost becomes like a subjective
translation where it's like i personally
think this is what they're trying to say
but it's not true 100 the same and i
feel that if people try and use that as
a way to learn grammar yeah then they're
going to get one nuanced way of learning
it which is not exactly
accurate yeah when i was watching the
american films obviously in japan yeah
they have the japanese subtitles
interesting
it is it is it is i'm like oh that would
be like a really heavy amount of slang
yeah i'll just translate it into
something extremely simple and mundane
that doesn't really convey the situation
well i don't think it does but yeah uh
but obviously it works the other way
around as well but like i watch i watch
uh actually you know it's quite helpful
watching japanese tv because they have
subtitles in japanese on the screen
every goddamn two seconds rip editors
but
yeah they have the subtitles on the
screen and i find it way easier to watch
japanese stuff with japanese subtitles
yeah because i know i know a fair amount
of kanji like basic stuff so i can
normally kind of
it really helps me
solidify the sentence because often i
just i'm just intaking and i don't see
anything to kind of like
lay it out and when i when i'm hearing
stuff and i can see the line
i can kind of be like oh that's what
he's saying because there's some words
that can mean like you know uh like
you and you say tara like
but then like tara can mean like so many
different things in so many different
contexts right if when it can be like
advice right it could be like a
recommendation of like oh you should do
this right so
it's really confusing because sometimes
if you stop paying attention for one
second and then you hear something like
tara and then you still you're like
trying to you're panicking to figure out
what way they're using this word yeah
that could mean so many things and so
it's really confusing but then having
the subtitles in japanese oh okay well i
just saw the first part and i glanced at
the second part i can figure out what's
going on i think every language is like
that though like even in english right
where it's like the word of for instance
it can mean a million different things
depending on the sentence right yeah and
japanese i think it's just like a little
more difficult because
you know it again like unlike in english
where there is spaces between words that
clearly distinguish between what this
word means what this next word means in
japanese we don't have that it's just
continuous flow i remember the first
time i saw like you know i i opened like
a japanese light novel or something and
i'm just like this [ __ ] terrifies me
it's it's just they're like
it's just one continuous line of text
i'm just like
what's that yeah the only thing that
stops it is a comma or a period yeah i
know right and everything else is just
nonstop
and i never thought i could get
terrified by like just letters before
until i opened like a japanese novel i
was like this this is just this is just
one line this is just yeah where's the
separation come on guys
i feel like this is a very small nitpick
you know how cause obviously in japanese
right the subject comes first yeah so
more often than not when they're like
explaining like plot twists and anime
it's so hard to like hype it up because
the subject comes first yeah so it's
like
gand was the killer killer or something
and it's not like and the killer was
can't it's always like no actually in
japanese we can do that yeah okay yeah
we can do that we're like you know for
example like uh like murder mystery
stories in japanese do this a lot okay
like you know normally if if someone
were to say like you're the culprit
right in english we can do the same
thing right you can say the culprit is
you or
you're the culprit right like same thing
in japanese you could say it gives a
taste so like you know uh like if i were
to say
you're the culprit right in that order
then it'll be hanyu
oh yeah
versus
which is you're the culprit which one
sounds more natural though because like
they're both natural okay because what i
noticed about english is that you know
it's just japanese
sorry yeah
no but what i've noticed is that you
know with the translation it with
translating the japanese like natural
english yes some english that reads
naturally like sometimes you can get the
same meaning across in english it just
sounds really jank you know especially
with how the sentence structure and
japanese grammar is right it turns out
language is like nothing alike
not every language is like english
like learning a second because like
obviously we've all had second languages
that we've never really learned yeah has
learning like a third language for you
made you appreciate welsh more hundred
percent
hundred percent
hundred percent straight up no no really
like yeah for sure like you know i take
it for granted but then again like i
also feel like god i've like i never
ever wanted to learn in my mind i always
say of the mindset of like you know i
know this is very close-minded but i was
just like i'm just gonna let's speak
english i already knew the language i
thought that way right yeah and
i still to this day i hate learning
languages yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] trying
to learn a third the [ __ ] is that what's
up with that what's up with that man i
want to learn a third language i just
don't really have the time right now but
the problem i mean is that you won't
like
unless you're like one of those people
who's just obsessed with languages and
learning them like i feel like you will
only learn the other language if you
need to yeah yeah which is the only
reason why i'm doing it like i'm i'm
finally at a point where i know people
like online they always don't know how
you're japanese and stuff and it's so
hard to convey how your japanese is when
you don't need to speak it yeah i don't
want to speak it online
sometimes because it's embarrassing like
you know like chris will always try and
get my [ __ ] japanese out and i know
why chris is [ __ ] doing it because he
wants to feel good about his chat
[ __ ] because obviously obviously
chris is japanese is better than mine
yeah right like not that much
when i see chris yes he has no problem
conveying a lot of like thoughts
when i'm with him he'll do anything he
can to not speak japanese because
he's all the same it's it's like the
same
thing he doesn't want to do it in front
of you because it's embarrassing because
he's going to feel like i've been here
for eight years i should speak better
yeah yeah and like yeah like you know
it's whatever whatever amount you want
to learn you can learn i'm i'm even
though i want to i want to get better
yeah i've gotten to a point now where i
can pretty much do everything except for
do government documents i can everything
is not a problem and i could barely do
that
so i can go to the bank that's how
that's how i know i'm my fluency is
increasing it's somebody who came here
literally knowing nothing i'm pretty
proud of where i've come from like how
far i've come but like you know it is
again it's it [ __ ] sucks online yeah
people oh yeah people are [ __ ]
because because people people expect you
to like reach a certain level by a
certain time sometimes i forget what
sometimes i forget a word that i should
know sometimes i forget an easy one
i'm exactly the same where like it's i
was putting in hours like every single
day for like a good good like two three
month periods
um and then i went back to england right
and it's it's like going to the gym
where you like build up this uh
you build up this routine and you're
like great i'm doing this routine and
then something comes along to [ __ ] over
that routine and then like it just
cascades and you miss a day and then you
miss two days and then you miss a week
and you're like [ __ ] now i'm starting to
forget you know i know yeah
and like that's that's where i've i'm at
now where like i was making such good
progress and then i went to england and
then it just cascaded and i'm like
trying to have to put the effort and to
relearn some of the stuff that i knew
before and now i just forgotten because
i wasn't putting the active hours in
every day yeah i've i've speaking of gm
i have really [ __ ] struggled to get
back into it like it is hard i forgot
how hard it was to get back into the gym
if you fall out yeah because you know
when you're going every week you don't
really get sore the next day much it
doesn't really happen because you're
probably eating the right thing your
body's used to you doing it yeah and
like i i didn't i rarely got like very
sore yeah now when i go i'm sore for
like four days because i haven't got a
month right so you combine that with
like
also having a busy schedule and i want
to go more but you need to go at least
once a week or more to kind of build it
up right yeah but now if i'm sore for
four days i'm not gonna go for those
four days and then i gotta pray that my
schedule isn't full on the other two
days that i i'm able and i want to go
but of course life isn't like that and
most of the time it's i'm doing
something i gotta go somewhere yeah so
it's like [ __ ] man like i'm i'm i'm
really trying to get back into this but
it is so goddamn hard to get back into
the gym as an adult when you fall out of
it yeah it is so difficult because most
people just aren't used to making a lot
of time for it and it's something that i
i will not
i will not empty my schedule to go to
the gym no no i to me it's like i i know
i should i should exercise i enjoy it i
really i really love going
but i want to do everything else first
yeah i want to prioritize my work first
yeah and then i'll go to the gym
i mean it's it's it's what it's you know
it's just being an adult right have you
signed up to a gym sorry i have not
signed up
i mean i mean like
are you going to
probably not i kind of like i kind of
had this realization where
the little free time that we have to
work with i'm either going to go to the
gym or i'm going to use that to
learn japanese and i chose like i made i
made the active choice to be like i'm
going to put whatever free time i have
into learning japanese that's my choice
because i'm not like i before i was like
i can do both i've got time to do both
and then what i realized is that i
didn't have time to do both and by
trying to do both i didn't i didn't
either
exactly and so i like i i knew i needed
to like because the thing is either with
gym or language learning i think
discipline is the most important thing
like it's like it's it's you
the idea is nice so i feel like you're
going to the gym every week or every day
or putting an hour of whatever you want
into learning japanese but it's not
gonna happen if you're not gonna like
commit to it yeah yeah and you need to
just be like strict with yourself to be
like i'm going to put up
i'm going to this is going to go beyond
me just
having this idea of i wanting to do this
thing and me just putting in like the
raw hours to do it
i i think one thing that i uh took this
is from tyler one stream as well right
of course is what he said right and
honestly i it really resonated with me
he he said that like he goes to the gym
a bunch right obviously because he's an
absolute human machine you ever seen
tyler1 this man is literally like insane
yeah he was like and and to this day
this like i still firmly believe this he
was like you know even if you have the
shittest day on earth if you if you go
to the gym and you work out you've done
something yeah you actively feel like
you've you've you've made some progress
on something yeah and like you know work
doesn't have to go right your
relationships don't have to go right
right but at least you've had that one
thing that you've done that was good for
you yeah and and it and it and and to be
honest right when you go to the gym like
the one thing i really loved about it
and and this is probably the reason i go
is because the the the day so i i like
to go in the morning yeah i don't really
like going at night it's not really my
thing
when i go to the gym in the morning that
the the rest of the day is like amazing
like my energy's high yeah i feel great
the next i sleep well i normally have a
good next day too as well so i just find
that everything improves when i go so
that's why i do like going yeah the [ __ ]
is it hard to do it oh yeah i mean like
i i like this year i opted to
get up at like you know around like
eight or nine a.m nine a.m later i've
been doing that as well yeah and just be
like even if like i got barely any
[ __ ] sleep the night before even if i
went to bed at like 3am yeah i always
try and get up at least like 9am latest
just because i know that in between 9am
and lunch if i get something done before
lunch i feel [ __ ]
yeah it's such a simple life hack where
yeah like like waking up early pack wake
up early the adults tell you oh you'll
feel better if you wake up early as a
kid i'm like shut up
let me stay up tall [ __ ] you let me stay
up till 5am playing video games see how
that hurts me i know who knew that it
hurt you yeah
the one good thing right about okay
there's two sides of this coin
so if you are waking up at nine all the
time even if you go to bed like five am
you have like a a night out you'll
probably still wake up at nine because
your body's like this is time to wake up
get up now yeah and i have been yeah you
feel [ __ ] all day yeah but at least you
still maintain the sleep schedule yeah i
mean yeah but on the other side i
remember when i used to wake up at like
one or two p.m it's not not my proudest
of days yeah i think we've all been
there i would wake up at this time one
good thing was that
one i normally just like didn't eat as
much like i found that when i'm awake
all day i'm eating a lot more mm-hmm
that's good or bad i wonder why yeah
yeah cause i'm just got more [ __ ] to do
i'm more active but less because i would
just eat a meal at like eight and then i
would go to bed yeah yeah at 4am
but
the other thing is when i go out with my
friends and we're going drinking i'm
getting really tired by like 10. and i'm
like [ __ ] bro cause i remember when i
would wake up at two yeah and we went
out yeah i'd be like four a.m what's
good i'm still good to go man yeah let's
go let's party let's keep going yeah and
everyone's like i'm so tired i'm gonna
get work tomorrow i'm like let's keep
going let's keep going i know and then
now i'm i'm that guy who's like dude
it's like it's like 9 p.m man i uh i
gotta get back soon you know
yeah it's so sad man i can't i it's so
hard for me to i remember yeah i
remember when i first like when we first
started coming to japan like me and joey
had this thing where every time i would
come we would do like all night karaoke
every time every single [ __ ] time and
then like twice a week we're gonna have
to do that when people come here you
know that right now
oh my god i'm like i'm like can we go in
the morning and just go all the way to
like 10 pm and then
content creators who want to come on
trash taste your mutuals with us on
twitter there's a very very small amount
of people watching this yeah yeah if you
come here please don't all come at the
same time yeah
i'm pleased we're gonna die
it's gonna happen though when the
country opens up there's just gonna be
like a mass [ __ ]
[ __ ] people just coming in the
country yeah because like i saw people
on twitter were like talking they were
like any other content creators want to
arrange a trip to japan when it opens up
right away and i was like please no no
always
that morning that train home or that
taxi home or that whatever however the
[ __ ] you get home is like the most
depressing thing in the world dude when
i was coming back from your housewarming
party it was like
like 2 a.m on a taxi and i'm like
god i want to die
i was like it was the most depressing
tactics i've been on so long there's
just something about going home after a
night out when you can see the sun that
is just
like that is like what am i doing i'm
like you're walking you're walking in
the streets and you're just like
everyone else is going to work yeah are
you like look at all these people with
an adequate amount of sleep in their
body [ __ ] them i feel hopeless
i feel like a homeless man roaming the
streets
of society and i'm just like going home
it's like a [ __ ] gremlin or something
right
oh my god yeah i remember that i used to
go out to like 4 a.m when you first came
here yeah i like that though
to me like we used to do it on the on a
whim but now i'm like it needs to be
yeah
i'm going to prep for that i agree we're
like this is a hard one boys we're going
hard okay
we're all gonna get drunk
i gotta like go to sleep really early
the night before so i can get like
enough sleep before my waking up at 8
a.m yeah oh my god no because like for
me i i luckily like if i want to stay up
i can stay up really easily but what
that just means is i just lose a day
it's just i i i lose a day if i stay up
late now it's
like
my actions have consequences at every
part of it who [ __ ] knew it's this
[ __ ] who's last alive he's
always the one up until like seven i
don't get it at like two sometimes i you
know
i don't really get much fomo anymore at
parties i don't really feel like i have
to stay up once i'm done i'm like later
guys if i'm the first to go to sleep i'm
the first to go oh yeah i'm no qualms
about it it's whatever my body's saying
i'm like all right later guys yeah
because i especially if i especially if
i'm i need to do something the next day
or they want to hang out again the next
day yeah i want to i want to be awake to
like spend time with you guys yeah of
course yeah exactly yeah we might dance
like i must stay awake
i don't know it's just when people are
there i'm just like i i wish to i wish
to converse now i wish to socialize
okay that i do feel a bit of firmware
about like i haven't seen my friends in
ages i'm like i really want to talk to
you
but i'm so tired yeah
well that's the thing right it's like
it's like if i
if it's just like a regular night right
yeah and i'm like i could stay up and do
whatever i'm doing until like 4am yeah
but then i think to myself i'm like this
is [ __ ] i can just do tomorrow morning
yeah so now it's like i don't have to do
it now yeah i mean it's different like
if it's like friends i haven't seen in a
while i'll [ __ ] sleep oh yeah that is
like the one exception where i'm like
yeah i'll be happy like 5am if it's just
like a normal night out with these lads
who i see every week i'm like guys i'm
getting a bit tired
next week i'm like alright i'm going to
bed [ __ ] you
true true i need a piss quickly oh my
god i'm sorry i didn't take i didn't
take one last time when we had a long
break man's woman bladder sorry turning
up your regular trash taste episode
because by the way did you know we
stream on trash taste now every single
tuesday at 7 p.m jst these times on
screen we will be live doing some fun
things maybe tasting food doing some
challenges this is a spelling bee why
weren't you here live watching at
americans we know you're asleep but come
and watch the streams so smash that
twitch link in the description down
below to come watch these streams live
and maybe you'll be on the chat on
screen somewhere i hope i'm pointing at
it right look one camera one camera
change the other camera with joey now
back to the middle camera back to the
camera with me
you're missing out on all this fun stuff
come on watch trash taste live trash
taste is on
twitch yep twitch.tv
podcast
i got this don't worry about it
tv slash days podcast 7 pm jst every
week until the end of december links
down in the description below come and
hang out with us see you then
hit that follow button going back to
like languages and stuff though like i
did have this thought
and don't mean to like sound elitist or
keep something else right but i just
like talking about [ __ ]
do you think you can truly understand a
culture if you don't have
if you don't like have at least like a
bit of an understanding of the language
because what made me think this was
learning japanese has really made me
appreciate thai and thai culture and
made me think about
my own language or my second language in
a way that i never thought about before
right yeah because to me learning a
language or like learning thai was just
the way i communicated to my mom and i
didn't like it didn't like i didn't
internalize just how much of my culture
was steeped into my language until i
started to try
learning japanese right and you know
like like we just said you can translate
things right you can translate ideas but
one thing one thing that i've found
learning japanese or like now
appreciating time or is like sometimes
you can't sometimes it's really hard to
translate a certain feeling you get from
a phrase
i think it's impossible to learn a
language without learning the culture
and vice versa i think you can learn the
language without knowing anything about
the culture really yeah i don't think
you can i think you can but
i mean what's the point yeah
but but you can't but like i i think
yeah of course you can because it's you
know it's a it's a set of rules and you
you follow them and you say the words
like right but just because you know
but like i would argue like you can
teach a robot a language it doesn't have
to understand the culture behind it but
it never that's a robot right what i'm
saying is that like well if that can be
done right that shows that i mean you
don't need to understand the culture
like yeah you don't have to understand
the culture but
i think if you want to
on the other hand if you want to
understand more about the culture no
that your question was knowing the
culture right yeah yeah yeah like i
think if you want to know more about the
culture the language is probably the
best way to do it yeah uh you know yeah
but i would argue that they kind of they
go hand in hand right like i feel
because the language of a country is a
culture
yeah so it's like i feel like yes you
could like you know as you said you can
teach a robot japanese right and again
you know speak back in japanese but
that's because that's a robo right there
it has no understanding of the actual
language and i feel in you can only get
so far
learning a language without knowing the
culture yeah yeah and only like
counterpoint to that it's like well on
the other hand it's like english is
constantly changing yeah as as are most
likely right like you go back 80 years
and you watch japanese you understand
the japanese that well right it's the
same thing you know languages are
constantly changing thing yeah but
languages are like culture as a whole
but in some ways culture is a reflection
of the language that changes over time
so that's that's that's exactly my point
right where it's it's it's it's been
like such a weird journey for me
learning japanese and just having like i
i feel like having like a different part
of my mind unlocked i don't i don't it's
it's so it's so i think it's limitless
it's it's so weird to change he used one
percent of his brain yeah it's so weird
to try to describe this to someone who
has like never tried to learn a language
or has or only knows one language yeah
you kind of like even you kind of even
like think differently with a second
language or like you know it's uh well
people have told me people tell me i
sound different when i speak japanese
yeah like i become a totally different
person but i'm like i would argue that
that's because
the japanese side of me that's speaking
japanese follows more of the japanese
cultural way of life
which is completely different to the
australian way of like is there any like
japanese concepts in language that you
think are like
have can't be translated or like are
difficult to translate
absolutely i mean like i mean yeah yeah
i mean you know it's i don't think it's
just like it's not just like one
you know phrase that can't be translated
or whatever i mean there's lots of yeah
you know
i would argue that there's a lot of
english words that can't be translated
oh that's definitely um but
yeah like boss influences right well you
know there's a lot of japanese words
that take an entire sentence to describe
in english yeah yeah right but like you
know there are some like especially like
you know i think the whole thing of like
just kanji especially is so difficult to
translate without fully first explaining
what the [ __ ] kanji even is right yeah
and i that's why i always found it
interesting that there are so many like
japanese like you know manga anime and
stuff like that that so heavily rely on
the japanese
language and therefore the japanese
culture yeah that
have somehow been translated and have
somehow still been understood by people
who have no knowledge of the language or
the culture yeah like it still baffles
my mind how popular the monogatari
series is outside of japan because that
show i've seen the subtitles a lot of it
gets lost in translation so hard yeah
but somehow people still enjoy it the
ideas are still there maybe i don't know
but i feel that like
you know it's it's interesting to see
like how a japanese person would react
to a show like that this is how a
non-japanese person would react to a
show both good both positive outcome
yeah but a completely different level of
understanding of what makes it good you
know and like the language also tells
the history of the country yeah yeah
well you know like you know we have a
lot of french words in english that yeah
from you know when friends had control
over england yeah japanese has tons of
english words and you know it also
japanese have a lot of words that are
like very cute sounding to reflect the
nature of japanese society right now you
know it all it all kind of reflects it
in a way that's really interesting and
kind of bizarre really it doesn't really
make much sense sometimes because
because i i realized when i went back to
england and i was speaking you know
speaking thai again to my mom that there
were just like some thai concepts and
thai like words that i just didn't know
couldn't be translated into english
until i thought about it like there's
this there's this concept of entire
called jai which means the heart right
and a lot of things
a lot of things revolve around this
concept of jai so basically
jai lan means hot heart so that means
you're impatient right and that's that's
the literal translation right
yen means patience cold heart right now
there's this word called nam jae which
means water flowing from the heart okay
and you explain that to english like
what the [ __ ] does that mean absolutely
water water flowing from the heart
disease
and it's it's like it's incoming yeah
water flowing from the heart means
it's it's someone's it's someone giving
genuine acts of kindness with no strings
attached they just want to be welcoming
and they are willing to give
just these genuine acts of kindness so
that everyone around them has a good
time and is more welcomed
and they do that with no strings
attached and like i'd like there is no
english translation for that like
because the closest thing you can say is
there's 90 words to explain it yeah
exactly the closest thing you can say is
like kinds but it's not it's not really
kind but like unless you know
thai i mean not unless you know thai but
like if you've been to thailand you can
feel this feeling right this feeling
that exudes from the country which is
why
which is why it's a great place to go on
holiday because everyone in there is so
welcoming because
a lot of people there have nam chai
and like it's it's so hard to explain
that into a different language because
in thai that is just a concept that you
feel because it's just so steeped in the
culture yeah and you feel it when you go
there but if you don't speak the
language then you don't have a proper
word to place on this feeling that you
feel people exuding same thing with
japan as well you feel a certain feeling
from you know that you know
someone who grew up in japan may have a
different way of thinking and a
different way of acting than say someone
who grew up outside of japan and there's
there's so many like
nuances with just culture and just
psychology that is so like steeped into
language that it's it's you can explain
it but it's from what i've from what
i've
from what i've experienced is the
difference between
explaining a joke and understanding a
joke you know yeah now now that i've
been you know an avid anime watch of my
entire life and i've had japanese
concepts explained to me it's like been
so weird actually
feeling some of these concepts as
opposed to just understanding them and i
think yeah like one concept i can think
of in japanese is like this idea of
reading the room or reading this yeah oh
yeah yeah it's all kooky yeah or like
air in japanese but like and you know we
say like when we read the room we say
kooky or which means to read the read
the air yeah but like it's not quite the
same as when you say reading the app or
reading the room in english yeah there's
like a whole other like it's it's like a
socio-psychological element to it that
it's like it's so important to read the
room and not reading the room or not
reading the air in japanese culture is
so like
not good like that's like you're
basically just you know societally just
it's a societal death basically yeah
because it's it's like a communication
within japanese society that doesn't
require words yeah it's a thing that
doesn't require words and it's like this
like non-spoken
social etiquette of sorts yeah that
japanese people have just hardwired into
their brain from a young age because
it's just so integrated into society and
you know
again that's like another concept where
you can explain it in another language
and i'm sure you know if you like looked
into it and understood it then you know
you'd be like all right i get what that
means you know i know how to say it in
this context but
you know
even for me
it's like i don't think i could fully
use or utilize the word or fully
understand what that word means because
i personally didn't grow up as heavily
in an environment like that yeah like i
grew up with it sure but i wasn't born
and raised in germany yeah so it's like
there's that sort of disconnect of
yeah as you said like understanding it
from an explanation and just
understanding it through osmosis yeah
and like
yeah it's it's i'm sure there's like
there's a lot of things that i've never
thought about in english as well that
maybe
maybe it's just like purely unique to
our culture in our language and it's
just like i don't know it was it's it's
just been it's just been really weird
it's made me think about things i've
always took for granted in my life where
like language was just me conveying an
idea and i just didn't realize that me
speaking english meant that i was
learning a part of the history that our
country has been through you know
that's just it's it runs way deeper than
i gave any credit for
i can see why people get into like
linguistics no i i didn't get it either
at first and i'm just like we're
literally just talking about linguistics
yeah yeah i'm not like for the longest
time i'm like wait so what do you study
linguistics yeah what the [ __ ] is that
i'm like do you know how to speak what
do you need to know what do you need to
know you already know you already know
the language
what more is there to learn about it but
now i understand i'm like it runs so
much deeper than just i know a lot of
words you know yeah it makes me in some
ways because i you know i'm fluent in
welsh and obviously i lived there all my
uh young adult life i guess oh yeah no
child life before adults yeah and uh you
know in some ways i'm like yeah i think
i'm i know the culture of course i know
the culture i'm like wait wait wait what
what exactly is it again i'm like like
sometimes i think oh man it's kind of
hard to define it it's kind of hard to
explain anything in some ways i'm just
like yeah it's like the uk but like way
more friendly like that's just kind of
it that's the culture like yeah very
similar but friendly i guess and more
focused on being expressive it's not
until you look at it through like a
third person person which is almost why
i feel like sometimes dare i say it's
like it's almost easier to
to look at a culture and it's totality
when you're not a part of it yeah yeah
because you can kind of like disconnect
your disconnect your experiences from it
yeah and sometimes welsh i'm like
someone's like explain welsh culture to
me i'm like ah
yeah that's what's so hard it's like is
it actually part of that country's
culture or is it just your experience of
living through that culture right right
that's what i i don't you know and
obviously something my experience is
totally different to someone else and so
therefore would it would have been
culture would be totally different would
it be easier to describe welsh culture
if the other person spoke welsh do you
think
it would probably be a good way to kind
of hash things out yeah
what do you
you know
getting a cultural um you know hearing
if i explain welsh culture to you it
could be totally different to how
someone else
might explain it to you yeah i feel like
we've experienced that quite a few times
on this podcast where we'd say something
yeah well oh yeah yeah all australians
like this and then
it's like no it's not no it's not the
only difference is there's not enough
welsh people to fact check me
is just happy to like be recognized so
it's just like okay
they're not going to call me out they're
going to be like it's just normal yeah
there's not enough people to even that
like they don't even watch they're like
yeah yeah they are so watchable but a
lot of them don't speak well
yeah but it's always been fascinating
whenever i've like experienced my
perspective of like australian culture
or japanese culture and there have been
people on the other side watching our
show being like no that's just you
and it kind of opens my up being like oh
yeah maybe it is just me dude that's so
weird do you get accused of being a fake
australian i think we've spoke about
this before sometimes
i've been accused so many times yeah
fake welsh online i think they're like
why does he sound english then why does
every english accent how does that
happen i think i think one time in an
episode i said that all australians own
passports and a bunch of australians
were like honestly
like a lot of
but all of my friends did
oh yeah
you also have a lot of uh international
friends as well right yeah
yeah
just different crowd yeah so then that's
when i realized i'm like oh it's not
actually just interesting so typically
as well the higher income the more
likely you're having a passport because
it's a luxury to travel and do all this
yeah and i mean my view of england is
very skewed from a lot of people's views
because i've only really grown up in the
south right you know i've very regards
from like the south is like the rich
part of the uk but the part that does
well for itself north is rough man yeah
i mean i i mean back uh it took me like
until like 24 25 before i even went
beyond
london
basically this people this is like all
the uk though
don't go above
to me like the midlands was just this
urban legend that people would make up
you know right yeah i'm just like
midlands doesn't exist it's it's all the
north it's all the north it just sounds
like a [ __ ] lord of the rings
the midlands no one goes to the midlands
you call it the north in australia do
you have like the north section
no we have we have the coast and not the
coast so this is a great debate in the
uk where does the north begin yeah right
because there's unfortunately there's no
[ __ ] big ice walls there's people in
the midwest
people in the midlands
the midlands wall yeah the people in the
midlands guess where they live the
middle yeah they don't want to be in the
north because the north has some nice
bad connotations right
you know so a lot of people debate where
the north is but there i believe there
was like a census of where the north is
and it's not a straight line it's this
weird diagonal line right it's a
cultural line right yeah yeah that goes
from like i can't remember where it's
it's a very
weirdly almost vertical line yeah it's
it's closer to being vertical than is
the horizontal if i remember correctly i
don't know it could be like 45 degrees
it just goes like this yeah that's why
when some people say connor you're not
from the north you're from wales and
it's like no no the welsh is the welsh
is northbound if you go to wells it's
the [ __ ] north bro like
you clearly haven't been to there you
would know isn't the latitude wise it's
like the same as most of the midlands
it's like almost same where i'm from is
almost the same latitude as liverpool
okay and that kind of error that seems
pretty north
i think i would say
it's from my understanding of where
liverpool is in my map yeah it's it
seems pretty it's pretty up there
to me it's like birmingham is you could
maybe argue isn't north but birmingham's
pretty northern as well i'd say i don't
know
i've met more people from birmingham
that would claim that birmingham is not
from the north
everyone from birmingham is like no
we're from the midlands midlands
that's an old man i think for us in
australia i'm gonna kill to saying that
yeah i think for us in australia it's
more so about because the mo the
majority of the population lives on the
coast
so for us the argument has always been
where does the coast
like the coastal cities stop and starts
becoming the inland cities
and like no one's been able to figure it
out
yeah because like i think for people on
the coast the coast seems a lot more
narrower than it actually is i think i
think i read something ages ago that was
something like in most countries like if
you don't artificially create a border
yeah like like east and west germany
it'll almost always become like a
north-south divide
and rarely becomes uh and even if it's
not geographically a north and south of
ireland it's called the north south
development yeah yeah yeah weirdly weird
i don't know why very well remember i i
i bring more to it i just didn't read
the rest of it
yeah think about a lot of countries with
divides of like wealth it's like germany
has a north south divide with like
bavaria being a rich part of germany in
the south and other parts which italy's
like that as well italy has it francis
like that too um a lot of countries are
like that north america most european
countries
is america like that i don't think
america is like that is what there's
like the south well the south
southern states and then
i was thinking but america is
it's like everywhere divided right yeah
everyone's killing everyone
yeah america is like a quad dog yeah
japan i guess kind of a little bit
no japan is like
tokyo kyoto and everywhere else no
kyoto tokyo everywhere else yeah
japan's a weird place no it's actually
actually no jokes
japan actually is east and west no it's
not okay it's kansai and kanto yeah but
then also i would argue in some ways
it's north and south because there's the
whole uh whole like hertz [ __ ] the
electrical grids being different that's
kanto and kansai yeah whatever but it's
like cut off from like tokyo it's like a
tokyo it's like a 45 degree angle
45 degree angle of tokyo upwards and
then to the east of it but it's up it's
not going like this way it's going up so
it's like kind of north south it kind of
goes to the south yeah yeah
also how did that happen oh it's
something to do with uh one side of
japan wanting to do european way and the
other wanting to do its own way and and
for some reason i don't know why japan
still has the whole 50 hertz 60 hertz
[ __ ] which by the way when you're
filming stuff is really [ __ ]
inconvenient yeah because if the change
you have to remember to change your
camera from 50 to 60 hertz otherwise
will be insane yeah like i filmed a
crane game in sendai but i think that's
also on 50 but then i think we filmed
something when we went to hiroshima yeah
which is 60. i think one of us forgot to
change one of the gopros and the gopros
is like just unusable because yeah it's
just like strobe yeah it's just like how
does this happen in such a but in other
ways i'm like this is of course this
happened in japan yeah imagine the bank
system of course there's something
stupid like that we're still trying to
phase out the floppy disks of course
oh my god once something is decided here
that's just the way it's going to be
yeah and there is no turning back there
is no thing
that's all that's all weekly complaint
about japan bit
welcome
all of them complained about america
with about complaints even talked about
anime
the bingo card is full
i'm sorry
i'm gonna [ __ ]
bingo and i'm going to [ __ ]
cyberpunk music
i don't know i you know i i think i love
talking about the difference between
countries so much but it also becomes i
guess tedious to a lot of the listeners
maybe i don't know i just i just i just
i definitely think that growing up
because i traveled a bunch and i was
very very fortunate that i travel a
bunch
definitely learned a lot about other
countries my dad lived in like germany
mostly so it's really cool getting to
learn about all these different cultures
and i'm obsessed with the us culture but
sometimes it's uh really hard to talk
about it online because sometimes
someone living in that culture is like
no yeah you're wrong but i also want to
give it give it a little talk about it
but something can be educated but but i
would argue that that's on that person
right because it's like yeah obviously
well okay it's a very skewed perspective
if i yeah and also if i say something
blatantly wrong then yeah i mean well
then yeah like france is a good country
you know if i say that then that's fair
enough that i'm you know
i'm joking
i'm joking that's a joke i'm british we
make the joke you can mock your uk go
for it yeah no but like i feel like
especially now that
now now that living in another country
like probably living in another country
and integrating into its society i mean
this is the first this is my first real
experience trying to integrate into a
society where i have not grown up in
yeah i have no prior experience in it's
just been a shot in the dark i give you
guys props for that it is it is
unlearning it's hard because it was
different for me living in thailand
because i'm just like yeah i've never
i've never properly lived in thailand
before but it's got like family there
right family that i've visited there
enough i speak the language i understand
the culture as we've just said um so
it's it's it was much easier for me to
integrate and there wasn't as many
surprises i wouldn't say i got like a
culture shock per se i don't know what
is culture shock i don't know what's
going on what is what is this shock is
when you go to a country and you realize
that something that you didn't think is
normal is normal in this country yeah or
like the daily norms that you did aren't
normal here normally you just rethink
the way you think
okay okay
i guess maybe we've had culture shock
but not like i had culture going back to
the uk
yeah reverse culture shock yeah i mean i
had more cultures
question to you boys question
questioning all right all right do you
find yourself more critical of your home
country after leaving said country yes
yeah oh okay
so it's really easy for me to look at
the uk and be like what a [ __ ] mess
but i knew it was a mess that i lived
there
okay but it was your mess it's true it
still is my mess yeah i still love it i
still love the uk but holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are we doing
there is a so
right now in the uk there's this there's
this there's like no truck drivers like
no people to drop you talking about the
fuel crisis no it's not that we have no
truck drivers oh okay because we stopped
letting uh immigrants in to drive trucks
right and so then turned out that we
were only hiring immigrants to drive
tracks before right and then suddenly
they were like uh who's going to drive
the trucks and so now there's no there's
no truck drivers and all these people
yeah and now they're like [ __ ] we should
we should have maybe like thought about
this
so then i'm not commenting on all that
[ __ ] because it's a [ __ ] minefield
but there was there was this uh now
there was this there's this news thing
on bbc
so because there's no truck drivers what
they've done or i don't know if this is
just like this could have been just news
bait or something i don't know what it
was but this clip was just so [ __ ]
funny i don't care if it's true or not
there was this bbc uh bit about how now
they were recruiting prisoners who had
truck licenses to drive trucks are you
serious yeah so so
whatever i don't care okay all right but
then they
they're like they're like meet steve
this is steve he's a truck driver and he
was in me
steve steve was arrested for smuggling
cocaine on a truck into the uk it was
just like
could they not have like
like i get it i get it i think he's a
great truck i was like this
they're trying to sell the public on
this and that is the one [ __ ] example
they give i'm like come on people are
not going to be happy with that people
like people don't want pablo escobar
managing their infrastructure you know
what i mean like people here
meet steve he ran over 70 people with a
truck the problem was that he was
delivered through the british people
being like immigrant truck drivers no
cocaine
drivers insane to me man it's like it's
like you can't make this [ __ ] up like
they would rather a guy who like broke
the law then get them get someone who
can't speak english well you know what i
mean he's [ __ ] up and so i i know
that's whole politics i don't i don't
give a [ __ ] but that that whole thing is
just [ __ ] absurd yeah but
it was just that the humor of it was
just the reason why i found it so funny
because it was just delivered through
that traditional bbc no opinion no
emotion vibe where it was just like the
british government has resorted to
hiring inmates
yeah this is steve he was caught
smuggling cocaine on a track it was just
like it was just so
not even a single emotion
and it was just so jarring
and chris sent me the clip it was just
so funny yeah i was like this is
so [ __ ] funny it's just oh my god
what's going on the absolute state the
absolutely state of truck drivers in the
uk state of the
uk oh my lord oh my lord bbc went
downhill since gone left that's yeah
that's that's i mean that's why i left
right
i got off you saw those stories
they reported that the best most
funniest way they could have i was very
happy with that sometimes it's just the
way they like bbc news it's just
sometimes the way they present it so
how can i what's what's the word because
they're still like the goals
standards of not inserting opinion in
terms of at least just the the broadcast
airing and like when they factually
presented they have a lot of articles
that are absolutely [ __ ] with full
opinions of garbage but yes
generally
the prime time tv when they're just
saying the thing normally it's good it's
it's the good it's a good example you're
telling it how it is yeah they're
normally like they've been a little bad
recently right
it's a shame really because the bbc was
kind of a gold standard and and
television
uh yeah it was and now it's kind of gone
it's like it was
and that's gone downhill when when they
reported that uh gundam as a transformer
i was like that was the final
that was the final stream they couldn't
even make the [ __ ] research to call
it gundam i put the letter of
resignation on the table the next day
i was like the audacity you know you
know how like actors send letters to
other actors they're like your
performance was amazing yeah yeah they
said god sent the letters to the bbc i
am disappointed the absolute state of
this new state what has happened to the
great bbc i want to strike this from my
cv so nobody ever knows i worked for the
bbc this is what you know
money i would like to boycott the bbc
i would like to rescind my employment at
the bbc please
yeah man it's just oh god because you
only you know you know when you're
living there you get to experience the
nice parts and the fun parts and now i
only just hear about the [ __ ] mess
that's going on with the like the news
articles and stuff yeah my parents being
like so the world is on fire yeah yeah
you know and they were like oh yeah
energy prices went up like 1 000 or
something they were like the energy bill
went from like 40 pounds to like 500
pounds and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on jesus christ oh my god yeah i
mean like
even
like deep during the pandemic when i
heard about the 5g things because i i i
i'm so bad yeah okay yeah i i remember
back back when it started we were just
like haha look at look at all the silly
americans yeah yeah yeah yeah
british people in the uk legitimately
think that crazy people only exist yeah
yeah no they don't they don't believe
that crazy people exist in the uk yeah
um
these news articles about people like
burning 5g towers in the uk came out and
the rest of the world were like yo get
your mans get your man so i'll just like
say my mans man
i'm part of japan now
uh japanese citizen uh
[Laughter]
it's really bad it's like it was it was
all the videos online of 5g towers being
torn down or like set on fire every time
i was watching i was like oh where was
he florida or something and then you
hear a really big thick british accent
it's my man
[ __ ]
oh god
it's pretty bad yeah because like i yeah
i don't know if we were just blind to
this when we were living there but i
it's oh it's just been exacerbated oh
it's been exacerbated yeah yeah yeah
it's like five years it's gone live
it's skyrocketed and yeah it's really
really tragic and i feel like especially
during like these past few years we've
seen like the the [ __ ] stupidest
parts of humanity just like on like on
[ __ ] front and center yep yeah i
think right they don't you know they
don't think they're being stupid
it's unfortunate that you know our
country was like part of that stupidity
we thought every country thinks they're
mean to it but we fact we soon find out
that we are we are not being just as
capable of being stupid any country with
internet it's going to happen to you
you know every single every country that
has the internet it's unfortunate yeah
do you know what i realized uh
you know like every cheesy hero movie or
every like cheesy heroic moment where
the hero asks the entire world to come
together and it cooperates like you
remember that scene in dragon ball z
where goku asks everyone to [ __ ] give
me your energy give him energy for the
spirit bomb i realized that's entirely
[ __ ] [ __ ] like imagine if that
tried to even imagine if that like
happened in real life you know like the
[ __ ] americans would argue whether
they have the right to not put their
hands up right japan would take six
months to approve any of their citizens
putting their hands up the uk would
start would start burning 5g towers and
australia would probably go back into
lockdown
they put their hands on the ground
like no one would [ __ ] put their
hands up
oh my god
i would like to see that i would like to
see that goku scene post coded let's
let's see how that turns out
i think it would go off for twice as
many episodes right it's like
it's just like there's just like the bad
guys just like i'm waiting goku has to
go on a pr trip around the world kissing
babies goku has to go and joe broken
just try to convince everyone
joe rogan
[Laughter]
so what you're saying is goku is that
everybody has to put their hands up yeah
really really
yeah people be like i don't know it's a
right-wing thing to say i don't know
about this majin buu character you say
he's the greatest threat in the universe
how come i haven't heard of him yeah he
sounds like a hoax to me
he's probably turning the frog's game
have you got any proof that he exists
that he's not some liberal something
made up by the liberals
it's liberal propaganda i tell you oh my
god someone someone needs to make a
political satire of dragon ball z that'd
be the funniest thing in the world
new grounds well you need to come out of
the dark ages and make that
it sucks just being like i don't give a
[ __ ] about any of this yeah it sucks
being in like yo you're all crazy yeah
what are you guys doing yeah just just
be normal
it's so hard it's so hard to be normal
because that in itself is a [ __ ] take
that's like what do you mean you don't
have strong opinions on this weird [ __ ]
that i read online
i just don't care man i'm just trying to
chill man i just think that like why
don't you be nice to people i don't know
it must be nice to have the privilege to
just chill
yeah but you know at the end of the day
i you know i it's one of those things
where i it's unfortunate because i don't
think inherently people i think there
are small amount of people that
genuinely are like extremely hateful in
a sense yeah i don't think you know it's
why i i hate demonizing any side too
much i don't like just saying one side
is right because i think at the end of
the day even though as long as they're
not posting harmful stuff which i'm
unfortunately they are
they are posting harmful misinformation
it sucks because i don't think that
anyone is
inherently
like evil or trying to spread hate i
think they genuinely just believe that
what they are spreading is going to save
people's lives or help people which
sucks because then then when someone
believes that firmly about it it is like
impossible to change their minds i i
think it's just it's been exacerbated by
the internet i mean it's it's like being
in social media
it's so easy just to fall in an echo
chamber right where you where because
you think a certain way and there's
nothing you get exposed to that
challenges you or challenges the way
you're thinking right because
you know in the old days you hear
something you hear something that you
disagree with and maybe you have a maybe
you have a debate or you know maybe you
you talk to someone about it but in here
you can just simply mute them or you can
just simply not follow people who have
that opinion i think i think that's the
problem i have with it it's like i don't
really mind people giving like extreme
opinions about things yeah on the
internet right and you know believing in
something that they firmly believe in
right the problem i have is that no
one's having a [ __ ] open conversation
about it right and no one is no one is
ready to be like
say say the opposite opinion to me i'm
listening and i will and i will try and
understand it the best i can
blah blah blah can't hear you i'm right
[ __ ] you mute you know
you know it's it's uh the internet's
very powerful because i think growing up
anything you read it's in a it's in
books it must be true yeah you've been
told that stuff you read or stuff that
you experience or stuff that you're told
is always true yeah so and even then
it's not sometimes right like i remember
when i was like 12 and i first came
across like the moon landing conspiracy
yeah
and like for like a week i probably
thought it was true yeah because i i
read it and i thought well that makes
sense this person explained it well
enough to me yeah and then you know but
i was 12. i was 13. or whatever you know
like you're a [ __ ] idiot you can't
think about stuff yeah you can't yeah
you can't be like oh maybe they cherry
picked you like they presented
information this all seems like it makes
sense in my world and that i understand
so it's it's uh it's tough and some
people i feel like almost kind of have
that mindset going forward and never
really like tend to think oh maybe i
should look at other stuff yeah what was
that quote like history is never written
by the losers or something like that
it's it's it's important because it's
like it takes energy and time to look at
the other side and a lot of people don't
have the energy in time to look at the
other side nowadays and it's just you
have to like train yourself to like kind
of like you have you have to go against
your you know your own gut feeling and
you're just like okay i have to
literally go out of my comfort zone and
see what the other side is saying which
is why i like on my social media i try
even if i don't even if there's someone
out there who i don't agree with i still
like sometimes follow them or i still
like sometimes want them to appear in my
feed so just so like i know what the
other side is it keeps you grounded yeah
i i do hate this idea that you can't
follow anyone who has like controversial
takes or anything on twitter i'm like
so what it's like you know you're not
promoting them if you're following them
it's like all right well just let them
[ __ ] follow them like yeah what harm
is it doing why would you want an echo
chamber i don't understand this thought
process of only experiencing your your
thought process and people who think
similarly to you yeah to me yeah i think
if you're just surrounded by nothing but
yes man that equally
maybe it's a little different but if
someone just said something that's a bit
yikes on twitter it's like i mean if
someone just gave an opinion right yeah
it's it's tough right pewdiepie got
cancelled for that or cancelled yeah i
remember like he's following he's ben
shapiro or something he's yeah yeah he's
[ __ ] he's right-wing bro or jordan
pizza or whatever like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
and i think that's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's that's like the next level of
just like oh
you it's not even you agree with this
person it's you are
you have a platform where you listen to
this person by by therefore you are
supporting them like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] maybe i just want to know what
the other side is saying because i think
it's interesting to see to have a
different perspective even if i don't
necessarily [ __ ] agree with it yeah
and like i think i think
a big reason why i just like don't have
the energy for like a lot of politics
nowadays or like this this spectrum of
mentality is that everyone has something
to say but everyone knows what they
stand against
but no one knows what they stand for
that's that's that's how i feel where
you can like a lot there's so many
people who say you can say this is bad i
disagree with this i disagree with this
person this i disagree with that person
but they've never told me what they
stand for or what you know what what
their fight you know what what their
opinions are standing for and i'm just
like well you know what you can just you
can discredit someone but you can't come
up with an argument for your own values
or your own views and i i think i think
that's why i [ __ ]
that that's why like i don't have the
energy for this anymore that's why
that's why i've started to just you know
i've i just listen to people i like
listening to people and i feel like even
listening to the other side of the
argument really broadens your horizons
even if it's something you don't agree
with or even if you think the other side
is [ __ ] stupid which you know you
know
certainly do it does keep you grounded
true and it does help form your vault
would you form your world view as well
yeah absolutely very eloquent there god
thank you very much thanks for coming to
my ted talk
very eloquent almost like the patrons of
today's episode oh my god
look at them they're not overly
opinionated
they probably are but they're also very
eloquent these these people would put
their hands up for goku
these people wouldn't burn 5g towers
but hey if you like to support this show
then make sure you go over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify yes what a good
outro
what a good [ __ ] night well i guess
thanks for watching bye gamers bye
[Music]
you